[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais demander aux photographes
merci alors ce soir nous allons entendre
les différentes personnalités que nous
venons d'accueillir pour clôturer ce
meeting
nous entendrons évidemment votre tête de
liste françois xavier bellamy puis le
président notre famille politique
laurent wauquiez mais j'appelle
maintenant sur scène henry lemoine maire
de pont-à-mousson vous pouvez
l'applaudir
[Musique]
merci beaucoup bonsoir à toutes et à
tous je voudrais souhaiter une
chaleureuse bienvenue à françois-xavier
bellamy ce soir à pont-à-mousson ville
lorraine à laurent wauquiez
et si on a passé une partie de
l'après-midi avec lui tout à l'heure
notamment recevant et je l'en remercie
les représentants du personnel de saint
gobain pam qui vit des moments
difficiles c'était important qu'un des
grands leaders de notre famille
politique vienne patron d'une famille
politique viennent les rencontres et d
écouter devrait saluer les candidates
nadine vincennes notre député sortant
arnaud danjean nathalie entre voisines
côtoie souvent tous les élus nationaux
départementaux régionaux tous mes
collègues du conseil régional qui sont
là en nombre ce soir envoie vous et puis
tout s'est tu et ceux sans qui les
partis politiques n'existerait pas c'est
à dire les militants les passionnés
c'est ce qu'ils font la vie politique
bravo à vous
bienvenue à pont-à-mousson qui est une
ville résolument européenne
c'est une ville qui a eu son rayonnement
qui a connu son rayonnement à travers sa
première université de lorraine qui a
été créée ici en 15 100 72 il en reste
un certain nombre de vestiges une
université qui était déjà très très
tournée vers des pays anglo saxons ce
soir médecine endroit et il en reste un
certain nombre de choses et de concepts
dans un certain nombre de domaines
une ville qui est encore tournés vers
l'europe et vers le monde à travers son
industrie son tissu industriel
nous accueillons ici un certain nombre
d'entreprises européennes qui sont
implantés sur la zone date 11 sur la
zone de lesménils et puis 1 1
l'entreprise éponyme pont-à-mousson est
ça qui est une entreprise mondialement
connu qui n'a pas foulé des plaques de
fonderie marqué pont-à-mousson
c'est notre grande fierté c'est une
entreprise qui a beaucoup d'activités au
niveau européen dans le monde et qui vit
aussi sur un certain nombre de
règlements européens et on l'a vu tout à
l'heure avec laurent des dérèglements
qu'il faut certainement changer
et puis nous sommes une ville également
tertiaire est une ville qui vit entre
ses deux grandes soeurs l'agglomération
nancéienne et l'agglomération messine et
nous faisons ce trait d'union dans ce
sillon lorrain
et puis je voudrais vous dire que je
suis très heureux de vous accueillir
aujourd'hui parce que comme militant de
base depuis longtemps on va pas citer
les cibles qui se sont succédé mais
depuis longtemps je suis je suis
adhérent à cette famille politique et je
pense que comme adhérents de base
je ressens la même chose que beaucoup de
nos compatriotes qui sont de droite de
droite et du centre est qui se sont
sentis un petit peu orphelin à un
certain moment de la campagne
présidentielle
et ça fait plaisir ça fait plaisir de se
retrouver de voir un candidat qui monte
j'espère que je vais pas lui porter
malheur mais je pense qu'il ya un fond
qui est très qui nous permet aujourd'hui
d'être raisonnablement optimiste on a
besoin de nouvelles têtes on a besoin
d'un nouvel élan et beaucoup de nous de
nos concitoyens
attendez cela attendre ce moment là ils
veulent reconstruire une droite et un
centre avec des valeurs qu'ils n'aillent
pas papillonner un petit peu partout
c'est beau les idées de rassemblement
simplement il faut une cohérence dans la
politique et cette cohérence là et bien
aujourd'hui on l'a au sein de notre
famille politique et nous en sommes très
heureux et je pense que depuis que
françois xavier était choisie eh bien il
ya un nouveau tournant qui un nouveau
déclic qui a pris sa place dans le monde
politique et je suis sûr que lors des
prochaines élections avec la belle liste
qu'ils n'emmènent eh bien il va
transformer cet essai et il va faire en
sorte que notre mouvement de la droite
classique du centre revivent et retrouve
c'est la place qui doit avoir qu'il
n'aurait jamais dû quitter
dans l'échiquier politique français bon
meeting
bravo à toutes et à tous merci beaucoup
henry je vais appeler maintenant sur
scène une colistière qui représente
l'union de la droite et du centre qui
est vice présidente du conseil
départemental de la moselle que vous
connaissez tous ici nathalie colin
oesterlé
[Musique]
je
nathalie merci beaucoup de ta présence
je voudrais que tu nous dises d'abord
pour ceux qui ne te connaîtraient pas
encore qui tu es et pourquoi tu as
décidé de s'engager dans cette belle
bataille des européennes
merci geoffroy merci a tous déjà d'être
d'être venus si nombreux c'est très
impressionnant pour moi je vous le dis
je voudrais avoir un petit mot pour pour
commencer pour hervé morin qui n'a pas
pu être là ce soir que je veux remercier
pour la confiance qu'il me fait pour toi
aussi
laurange d'avoir un petit mot parce que
tu as su bâtir cette union avec avec
beaucoup d'intelligence et m'accueillir
avec beaucoup de bienveillance et je
t'en remercie
alors oui je suis je suis centriste
depuis bien longtemps et nous les
centristes il le rappeler nous n'avons
jamais failli je crois qu'il est
nécessaire de redire ce que nous sommes
et notre positionnement sur l'échiquier
politique parce que nous avons connu des
moments difficiles des période pas si
lointaine où l'on a vu les uns et les
autres
quitter le navire mais nous nous sommes
toujours restés droits dans nos bottes
et et fidèles à nos convictions
je crois qu'il est nécessaire de le
rappeler
cette cette famille de la droite et du
centre c'est celle au sein de laquelle
nous sommes associés dans beaucoup
d'exécutifs locaux ses salles au sein de
laquelle j'ai travaillé que nadine
morano
lorsque nous étions conseillère
régionale régionale dans l'ancienne
région lorraine
et la question qui se poserait si
n'étions pas là aujourd'hui avec vous
c'est par quelques curiosités ne serions
pas unis pour porter ensemble ce projet
pour l'europe que nous partageons alors
je suis vice présidente du département
de la moselle élus de metz depuis 2001
et cher laurent cher françois xavier
vous êtes ici au coeur d'une région
européenne européenne frontalière de
l'allemagne du luxembourg la belgique et
dans cette région où je suis élue en
lorraine en moselle
plus particulièrement la terre de robert
schuman père fondateur de l'europe de la
paix nous nous vivons l'europe au
quotidien européenne par sa culture
européenne par son histoire
transfrontalière par sa géographie
notre région est la porte vers l'europe
du nord et de l'est
notre région c'est celle de
l'apprentissage de la langue du voisin
est une priorité dès le plus jeune âge
en moselle nous comptons cent mille
travailleurs frontaliers dont 80 milles
qui travaillent qui part travailler tous
les jours au luxembourg
seize mille ans art 5000 en belgique et
dans notre région nous cultivons une
amitié forte avec nos voisins européens
alors nous sommes aujourd'hui le 9 mai
le jour anniversaire de la déclaration
de robert schuman considéré comme le
texte fondateur de la construction
européenne et alors que cette europe
doit nous protéger face à la
mondialisation au défi migratoire vous
en parlerai tout à l'heure écologique et
économique
cette europe est aujourd'hui menacée
elle est menacée tant par les populistes
de tous bords qui voudraient
déconstruire l'europe que par les
partisans d'une europe
béate alors oui nous sommes profondément
européen
mais oui nous croyons qu'il faut
refonder la l'europe et être capable de
remettre en cause un schéma qui ne
correspond plus aux attentes de nos
concitoyens
l'europe ne se fera pas d'un coup ni
dans une construction d'ensemble elle se
fera par des réalisations concrètes
créant d'abord une solidarité de fait
cette phrase est extraite du discours
fondateur de robert schumann et c'est
bien cette europe là que nous voulons et
c'est pour cette europe là que nous nous
engageons une europe des projets une
europe des territoires une alchimie
intelligent 30 entre la nécessité d'
europe sur des sujets fondamentaux et la
nécessité de la nation sur des sujets
qui relève de notre souveraineté
françois xavier nous avons une chance
immense de t'avoir pour porter ce projet
tu es un candidat formidable tout le
monde le reconnaît
tu parles vrai tu peur des valeurs
fortes
ton message politique est construit avec
une intelligence rare
tu redonne du sens et de la noblesse à
la politique
loin des discours sur années de
politiques désuet merci pour les sports
que tu fait naître chez nous dans nos
coeurs c'est grâce à toi et à toute
l'équipe talentueuse qui t'entourent que
le 26 mai j'en suis convaincu nous
gagnerons
merci à tous nathalie
merci de ton témoignage merci d'avoir
joué le jeu de t'exprimer or pupitre et
merci surtout de cette belle union de la
droite et du centre qui donne une très
grande force à notre liste alors avant
d'accueillir celle que vous attendez
tous je vous invite à regarder
sur les écrans cette petite vidéo la
sécurité doit être une priorité absolue
pour l'avenir de l'europe et pour
l'avenir de nos enfants
j'attends de l'europe qu'elle qu'elle
lutte contre la menace islamiste qu'elle
protège nos frontières les républicains
font de la sécurité un enjeu majeur de
leur programme
c'est pour ça que le 26 mai prochain aux
élections européennes je voterai pour
les républicains
pour moi la culture européenne devraient
être réaffirmés et c'est reparti du
programme des républicains la pac
aujourd'hui représente une grosse partie
du revenu des agriculteurs
on a besoin d'une pac forte pour la
modernisation de nos exploitations
l'objectif c'est le soutien de nos pme
la préservation des savoir-faire rare
des savoir faire d'excellence pour
l'europe et pour la france
je voterai le 26 mai prochain dans le
cadre des élections européennes pour les
républicains
je pense vraiment qu'il faudrait inciter
tous les jeunes à partir en erasmus pour
découvrir la civilisation européenne et
c'est pour ça que je voterai pour eux le
26 mai prochain
les républicains des propositions
concrètes et c'est pour ça que le 26 mai
j'irai voter pour les républicains
aujourd'hui nous avons un besoin énorme
de reconquérir des parts de marché car
le marché intérieur
et n'est plus suffisant pour les
transporteurs français nous avons besoin
de cette harmonisation au niveau
européen pour défendre le transport et
pour l'avenir du transport routier
français
l'intelligence artificielle et une
humeur et font partie intégrante de nos
vies
la france et l'union européenne doivent
investir et soutenir massivement nos
entreprises et nos startups pour ne pas
qu'on se laisse dominer par une
concurrence d'autant plus omniprésente
et de plus en plus féroce de la part de
la chine et des usa
les républicains ont des réponses
concrètes pour l'europe de demain
c'est pour cela que je voterai heller le
26 mai prochain aux élections
européennes
elle a appris le militantisme politique
sous jacques chirac
elle a ensuite servi nicolas sarkozy
comme ministre de l'apprentissage de la
famille et de la solidarité
elle est aujourd'hui une députée
européenne affirmé est reconnue et en ce
jour de l'europe elle est la preuve
vivante que l'on peut aimer l'europe et
être patriote vous avez bien compris je
viens de dresser le portrait robot de
nadine morano
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous cette salle de
pont-à-mousson et plein merci monsieur
le maire merci cher henri dès toujours
là au rendez vous de nous accueillir
dans cette salle de pont-à-mousson dans
cette belle ville entre nancy et metz et
je voudrais remercier laurent wauquiez
le remercier lui rendre hommage et lui
dire combien le travail de fond qu'il a
fait pour reconstruire notre famille
politique la rebâtir alors que nous
avons perdu l'un perdable alors que la
défaite que nous avons subie à
l'élection présidentielle de manière
historique fait que nous avons
évidemment crée de la déception il y a
fallu rebâtir cette famille et si vous
êtes là aujourd'hui c'est parce que
partout dans les territoires nous sommes
mobilisés laurent est un président qui
fait le boulot qui a mis les mains dans
le conduit
et si ça se voit peut-être pas dans le
travail ou dans médiatique dans ce qu'on
veut voir
d'un point de vue médiatique moi je peux
vous dire que sur le terrain dans nos
fédérations ça se voit alors je voudrais
remercier aussi tous les présidents de
fédérations qui sont là au premier chef
éric pense elle finit qui est le
président de la fédération de
meurthe-et-moselle
tous les présidents de fédérations les
quatre départements de la lorraine mais
aussi les secrétaires départementaux
les délégués de circonscription oui
bravo patrick les délégués de
circonscription tous nos cadres les
républicains qui participent à cette
reconstruction de notre famille les élus
les parlementaires qui sont ici présents
nombreux les conseillers régionaux
les conseillers départementaux et vous
les militants ceux qui ont des
convictions à défendre ceux qui
s'engagent au quotidien
et quel que soit votre âge du plus jeune
des plus jeunes ont peut-être plus âgé
parce que claude blick qui doit être
dans cette salle
et là claude il a allez levez vous
claude levé vous qu'on vous voit levé
vous allez levez vous allez claude
l'autre blick à 81 18 ans il est le
doyen de cette assemblée et il est avec
nous et hilarant il ira voter pour les
républicains
merci claude merci d'être là merci merci
d'être tous là parce que vous savez on a
un président de la république qui
voudraient nous effacer qui
souhaiteraient que les républicains
n'existe plus qu'il y ait juste un match
entre le front national et lui il
voudrait que la démocratie se résume à
un duel et ils voudraient nous enfermer
dans un étau eh bien vous êtes la force
qui démontre que les républicains existe
que les républicains sont engagés dans
une vraie dynamique pour ces élections
européennes et que les républicains
n'ont pas encore dit leur dernier mot
sur cette échéance il nous reste dix
sept jours et laurent wauquiez au delà
d'avoir rétabli notre famille politique
il a eu la judicieuse idée parce que
nous en avons parlé
la judicieuse idée de se dire pour cette
élection européenne
j'ai plusieurs possibilités
il aurait pu choisir morano qui avait
fait un très bon score dans la
gigantesque
il aurait pu choisir arnaud danjean qui
est spécialiste des questions de
sécurité
il aurait pu choisir une autre
personnalité et il a voulu tenter le
défi de choisir
françois-xavier bellamy je vais vous
dire je vais être franche entre nos
mains je ne le connaissais pas
et laurent le 10 mai rencontre le tu vas
voir si franchement il est très très
bien il est venu me voir comme il est
allé voir d'autres responsables
politiques et je me suis dit mais quelle
chance d'avoir une personnalité comme ça
qui vient qui s'engagent et qui vient
nous rejoindre c'est un défi difficile
d'être tête de liste dans une élection
européenne
c'est un enjeu majeur il le sait il est
parti dans cette campagne avec un sac à
dos lourd lourd des déceptions que nous
avions suscité engendré chez nos
compatriotes et qui au jour après jour
au cours de cette campagne déleste ce
sac parce que il arrive à convaincre
parce qu'il allie arrive à séduire et
qu'au fur à mesure
et bien nous voyons que françois-xavier
bellamy va arriver au sprint final bien
léger mais fort de toutes nos
convictions forts de nos forces port du
travail que nous ferons sur nos
territoires pour faire gagner la liste
des républicains alors vous savez cet
enjeu il est majeur pourtant on voit
bien que monsieur macron a essayé de
stériliser le débat nous sommes à 17
jours de cette échéance est depuis des
semaines et des mois on voit que nous
sommes enfermés dans le grand débat le
grand blabla les grandes par lot est
d'ailleurs dans le programme de monsieur
macron porté par madame loiseau il veut
aussi faire une grande conférence
européenne pour pour rebâtir l'europe
en fait il veut exporter son grand
blabla au delà des frontières
eh bien nous nous n'en voulons pas et
puis c'est quand je quand je vous
regarde dans cette salle je comprends à
quel point vous pouvez être motivé par
ce que j'ai lu la presse
évidemment ce matin et comme vous comme
beaucoup je découvre que monsieur macron
va rembourser va rembourser la cg qu'il
a pris dans la poche des retraités alors
appelez vous sur le plateau de monsieur
jean pierre pernaut vous aviez monsieur
macro qui disait avec beaucoup de culot
mais je dis merci
retraités merci parce qu'ils devront
faire un effort on leur désindexer
retraite on leur colle une augmentation
de la cg mais je leur dis merci
et bien moi avec ce que j'ai lu ce matin
j'ai envie de dire au président macron
qu' il faudrait qu'il demande pardon aux
français
pardon ont retraité de leur avoir pris
de l'argent dans les poches pour se
rendre compte qu'il a fait une grosse
erreur et d'ensuite d'aller les
rembourser et bien quand je vois ces
neuf millions de retraités qui ont perdu
en pouvoir d'achat
quand je vois qu'au quotidien c'est la
cible du gouvernement
mais je voudrais juste dire dans sept
pays
dans ce pays la lorraine dans cette
terre de lorraine qui incarne aussi le
travail l'industrie bien que franchement
les retraités qui touchent leur retraite
ce n'est pas une allocation c'est un dû
c'est un dû et que les retraités
aujourd'hui ceux qui sont à la retraite
maintenant ils n'ont pas travaillé 35
heures ils ont travaillé beaucoup plus
ils ont fait pour beaucoup ici les trois
huit
ils ont fait du travail difficile elle
leur retraite
elle est méritée alors je le dis
monsieur macro demander pardon et
surtout ne recommencez pas à toucher au
pouvoir d'achat des retraités
bon écoute et tu as on va pas se mentir
ça fait deux ans que le président de la
république est élu
ça fait quasi six mois que la france est
dans le chaos que nous sommes et on le
voit bien que ce gouvernement est
incapable de résoudre la crise sociale
ni gilet jaune qu'il est incapable
aujourd'hui de rétablir véritablement la
sécurité et que les français se demande
chaque samedi dans quelle ville et ça va
casser dans quelle ville ça va cogner et
ça c'est la démonstration que nous avons
aujourd'hui au pouvoir un président qui
a simplement été élu par défaut alors
moi ce que je ne voudrais pas c'est
d'avoir aussi à l'europe des députés
européens dont on voit la constitution
de la liste de madame l'oiseau qui
associe monsieur qu'enfin avec l'ancien
président des gia qui apprécient qui
associe des personnalités ou aux propos
contradictoires et dont les propositions
ne vont pas dans l'intérêt de la france
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que vous
savez ce qui va se jouer le 26 et j'ai
été étonné parce que français et bellamy
hier était une émission de radio hier
matin je l'écoutais avec beaucoup
d'attention
c'était le jour du 8 mai nous fêtions la
capitulation de l'allemagne nazie et au
cours de ces commémorations et bien ce
qui sont importantes pour nous les
journalistes n'ont pas absolument pas
dit un mot à françois-xavier bellamy sur
ce qu est la clé de voûte en fête de
l'europe c'est-à-dire la paix alors
heureusement françois xavier a su placer
cette phrase va mais a tonné aujourd'hui
c'est important c'est le 8 mai 45
alors si j'ai demandé à claude qu'à 98
temps de se lever et de le remercier de
sa présence c'est aussi pour ceux qui
sont derrière nous pour tous ces jeunes
parce que vous voyez dans cette campagne
on ne parle pas beaucoup de la paix mais
moi j'appartiens à la première
génération qui n'a pas connu la guerre
ma mère m'a raconté la guerre nos grands
parents nous en raconter la guerre mais
moi j'appartiens à cette première
génération qui n'a pas connu tout comme
mes enfants ne la connaissent pas et
comme je voudrais que mes petits enfants
ne la connaissent pas non plus alors on
a l'impression que c'est rien mais moi
je peux vous
dire que être dans un territoire de 500
millions d'habitants qui vivent en paix
et bien c'est devenu un exploit et ça
c'est le message des pères fondateurs ou
nathalie colin oesterlé a eu raison de
rappeler que nous sommes ici en lorraine
sur la terre de schumann et que les
pères fondateurs de l'union européenne
se sont dits plus jamais ça et ce
message il est important parce que c'est
un devoir que nous avons à transmettre
cette paix mais au fond qu'est l'europe
voulons nous et quelle europe
allons nous proposer à nos compatriotes
nous nous savons ce que nous voulons
nous nous ne voulons plus
d'élargissement nous considérons qu'à 28
eh bien nous sommes assez dans cette
europe nous considérons que c'est déjà
même beaucoup et que cette construction
européenne
si nous n'y prenons garde eh bien il est
déjà tellement fragilisé qu'elle
pourrait imploser l'intérieur donc plus
d'élargissement nous sommes clairs là
dessus monsieur macron ne l'est pas nous
ne voulons pas d'élargissement et nous
disons très clairement à la turquie est
ce que vous avez entendu monsieur macron
être clair sur ce sujet la turquie n'a
rien à faire dans l'union européenne
nous sommes nous clair et précis quand
nous parlons de ce qui nous semble
essentiel est ce que françois-xavier
rappelle régulièrement à savoir la
civilisation européenne défende nos
valeurs nos racines nos racines judéo
chrétiennes sans avoir peur de le dire
et de le revendiquer
parce que vous venez vous et allez à la
cathédrale notre dame de reims 1 mais en
france il y à 40 mille lieux de culte
chrétiens et ça c'est notre histoire
c'est notre patrimoine qu'on soit
croyant ou pas croyant eh bien la france
a des racines chrétiennes
notre civilisation européenne aussi il
faut le revendiquer il faut avoir la
volonté de l'inscrire dans notre été
pour dire à ceux qui veulent venir chez
nous qui nous sommes enfin
nous avons dans cette région de lorraine
terre de jeanne d'arc terre de verdun
terre d'élection aussi choisi par
philippe séguin terre de antoine veil
terre nantua les nouvelles je te cherche
ac
jacques lamblin le maire de lunéville
terre d'emploi nouvelle puisque le mari
de simone veil étaient du lunévillois et
nous avions beaucoup de discutions
ensemble avec simone et antoine bell
j'ai eu l'honneur d'aller d'ailleurs à
leur domicile parisien nous nous sommes
rencontrés à de nombreuses reprises et
je sais à quel point elle était attachée
elle aussi à notre civilisation à ce que
nous voulions en faire et quelle a été
la première femme présidente du
parlement européen
alors nous avons des fragilités il faut
le dire
donc nous nous voulons remédier à ces
fragilités nous voulons le faire parce
que si nous avons créé l'espace schengen
de libre circulation des personnes et
les biens auxquels nous l'aura nous
sommes attachés nous sommes une région à
trois frontières
nous sommes attachés à cette libre
circulation des personnes et des biens
mais nous voulons pour que cela
fonctionne correctement sécuriser nos
frontières extérieures de l'europe
ceux qui viennent chez nous et bien
doivent pouvoir demander l'asile
avant de mettre un pied sur le sol
européen
je sais au parlement européen je suis
membre de la délégation en charge des
relations avec le parlement panafricain
le discours que je tiens devant vous je
le tiens en afrique de la même manière
jeudi les bateaux en provenance du
continent africain ont vocation à
retourner vers le continent africain
les demandes d'asile doivent être
déposées sur le continent africain
et je le dis aussi parce que j'ai vu que
dans le programme dangereux d'ailleurs
de madame l'oiseau voulait faire un
pacte pour l'afrique mais vous savez que
chaque année nous donnons 17 milliards
d'euros pour le développement de
l'afrique
17 milliards d'euros par an et donc moi
je veut conditionner ses aides à
l'afrique
en contrepartie de leur maîtrise de leur
immigration et à ce qu'ils reprennent
aussi leurs ressortissants arrivé en
situation illégale sur notre territoire
la réalité c'est que les européens ne
peuvent pas payer deux fois
ils ne peuvent pas payer pour le
développement en afrique et payer une
seconde fois pour pour aider ceux qui
sont arrivés en situation illégale sur
notre territoire
ça n'est pas possible et pourtant
pourtant le développement de l'afrique
est un enjeu majeur
est ce que vous savez que nous français
nous représentons 0 85% de la population
mondiale même pas 1% que si nous sommes
seuls comme voudraient le faire le front
national c'est à dire recroquevillés sur
nous-mêmes mais nous serons désemparé
faible envahi notre force c'est d'être
unis
notre force c'est d'être unis mais c'est
d'avoir aussi notre propre politique
migratoire
parce que je le dis les français doivent
pouvoir choisir qui vient sur son
territoire les français doivent pouvoir
choisir qui vient sur leur territoire et
ceux qui respectent nos coutumes nos
lois parce quand on veut venir en europe
on ne vient pas en importance sa culture
je veux que nous ayons un discours ferme
contre l'islam radical
sur l'immigration parce que ceux qui
vous disent que c'est une forme de
générosité met à mal la dignité humaine
combien de bidonvilles
avons-nous maintenant en région
parisienne plus d'une centaine est ce
que la dignité humaine c'est de voir des
gens vivre dans la rue de manière
déplorable et ça n'est pas acceptable ce
n'est pas acceptable non plus de voir
des jeunes arrivés du continent africain
qui sont hébergés dans nos centres celui
de vendeuvre et surchargé on a ouvert
l'office national des forêts avec as
avec un centre dédié aux jeunes arrivés
d'afrique subsaharienne
eh bien ça n'est pas possible parce que
ceux qui viennent d'afrique notamment
des pays qui ne sont pas en guerre comme
la côte d'ivoire comme le mali comme le
cameroun doivent repartir chez eux il y
à une directive européenne qui est la
directive dite retour parce qu'on parle
souvent de sueur transposition il faudra
aussi qu'on parle aussi de l'asu
transposition parce que cette directive
permet le retour des mineurs non
accompagnés
s'ils sont accueillis chez eux par un
centre d'accueil par un membre de leur
famille ou para tuteur alors moi je vais
vous dire il faut que nous soyons fermes
les français attendent de nous une
europe sécurisé par leurs frontières
une europe dans laquelle on respecte le
travail et je terminerai par un mot vous
savez nous sommes allés avec avec
laurent wauquiez rencontrés avec
monsieur le maire de pont-à-mousson
rencontré l'intersyndicale de
saint-gobain
il y a un thème essentiel pour nous
c'est que nous ne pouvons plus laisser
l'europe l'union européenne ouvertes à
tous les vents
quand je vois que les dents une
possibilité de voir un rachat par les
chinois de saint gobain dites vous que
toutes les canalisations qui assure
l'eau potable qui est stratégique pour
nous et que toutes les plaques que vous
avez vu il a eu raison de le dire il n'y
a pas un pays on n'a pas une plaque pam
sur sur les sols les plaques d'égout moi
je crois que c'est important de dire
maintenant stop on a des clauses qui
nous permettent de protéger les
investissements étrangers sur notre
territoire on doit se protéger
on doit prendre des mesures qui
permettent de protéger nos emplois et
moi je ne veux plus de concurrence
déloyale
je veux la réciprocité commerciale je ne
veux plus que nous qui sommes ouverts en
termes de marchés publics à 95% nous
ayons comme la chine un pays qu'il ne
s'ouvre pas qui est à 0% sur les marchés
publics
les etats unis qui protège ses marchés
et nous ne protégeons pas eh bien il
faut changer de méthode
nous voulons protéger nos emplois nos
industries et pour cela il faudra que
nous ayons une politique de contrôle des
investissements étrangers
c'est ce qu'a fait d'ailleurs alain
proust à l'initiative de notre
présidente délégation au parlement
européen et je voudrais aussi saluer mon
ami arnaud danjean qui est spécialiste
des questions de sécurité qui fera
équipe avec nous dans cette nouvelle
aventure
en fait j'aime en terminer par un
dernier mot tu me permets c'est pour toi
disons que vous avez mis les spots fait
chaud l'un s'était en fait c'est pour
nous faire disparaître de la scène
alors non mais je voudrais dire un mot
sur geoffroy didier parce qu'aujourd'hui
il fait le monsieur qui accueille et
geoffroy didier vous le voyez à la télé
souvent sur les plateaux et moi j'ai
toujours défendu même sa candidature sur
la liste aux élections européennes
la dernière fois parce que je trouvais
que c'était un garçon qui était très
talentueux et je trouvais qu'il était
très talentueux mais je le pense encore
aujourd'hui
il est au parlement européen
il y reviendra et je m'en réjouis alors
je voudrais vous dire simplement ici
vous êtes allé mille dans cette salle
c'est bien mais j'ai besoin que chacun
d'entre vous allez convaincre ou moins
ou moins 10 personnes
prenez vos calepins regardez vos amis
votre famille vos proches vos voisins
mais à les convaincre
parce que moi ce que je veux c'est que
françois-xavier bellamy 1 dans la
dernière ligne droite et bien il nous
gris emmanuel macron et la liste de
nathalie loiseau parce que quand on nous
mais quand on nous met en troisième en
troisième position
ben moi je vais vous dire que c'est pas
la place de la droite et du centre
alors je veux bien qu'on tente de nous
effacer mais je pense qu'avec françois
xavier bellamy est avec vous tous
on va réussir on va faire gagner cette
liste pour les élections européennes
nous ferons gagner les républicains et
surtout nous ferons gagner nos
convictions pour la france au sein du
parlement européen
nous devons revenir avec une délégation
forte c'est entre vos mains que ça se
passe c'est votre travail c'est votre
énergie
j'ai confiance en vous by pont-à-mousson
vive la france et vive l'europe
ce ne sont pas des applaudissements que
nadine mérite mais une véritable ovation
merci nadine reste avec moi reste nadine
parce que avant d'écouter dans quelques
minutes
le président de notre famille politique
laurent wauquiez qui redonnent des
couleurs et de la force à la droite
je vais vous demander d' accueillir très
chaleureusement celui que j'ai qualifiée
de divine surprise de cette campagne
je crois que ce mot n'était pas vain
nous sommes très fiers d'être ses
colistiers vous pouvez ovationné
françois-xavier bellamy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes chers amis je confirme ce que disait
nadine mais je crois que c'est pas les
spots
il fait très chaud ici ce soir parce que
c'est votre chaleur qui nous porte
c'est votre enthousiasme qui nous
conduit dans cette élection européenne
et je voudrais vous dire à quel point
c'est une joie immense de vous voir si
nombreux ce soir ici à pont-à-mousson
merci infiniment monsieur le maire pour
votre accueil dans cette ville
emblématique de l'europe emblématique de
la lorraine et de la france bien sûr
merci d'être si nombreux ce soir d'avoir
pris de votre temps d'être venus parfois
de loin pour partager avec nous cette
soirée au coeur de cette campagne pour
une élection que tout le monde pourtant
10 est joué d'avancé
nadine tu viens de le dire rien n'est
joué d'avancé le fait que vous soyez là
si nombreux le prouve encore nous avons
devant nous dix sept jours qui vont être
décisifs 17 jours pour pouvoir faire en
sorte que notre famille politique relève
la tête et je crois que nous le devons
avec toi laurent derrière toi nous le
devons non pas seulement pour notre
famille politique pour cette union de la
droite et du centre
mais nous le devons pour la france parce
que et tous les parlementaires qui sont
là si nombreux ce soir le savent mieux
que moi le débat qu'on voulait nous
imposer n'offrent aucun espoir politique
et nous sombrons dans une forme de
désespérance dans cette espèce de mise
en scène d'un faux clivages absurde sans
véritable alternative dans ce clivage
entre populiste et progressiste que le
président de la république a rappelé
encore aujourd'hui comme si on avait le
choix qu'entre être pour ou contre
l'europe comme si on avait le choix que
d'être blanc ou noir gentil ou méchant
en avant ou en arrière comme si la vraie
question n'était pas celle de savoir
quelle europe nous voulons et c'est de
cela bien sûr qu'il faut parler ensemble
ce soir c'est de cela que nous parlons
depuis trois mois avec toute l'équipe
qui nous accompagnent dans cette
élection européenne
je voudrais remercier de tout coeur tous
ceux qui partagent avec moi cette
aventure depuis le début de cette
campagne
remercier en premier lieu tous nos élus
locaux ils sont nombreux ici ce soir les
élus municipaux les élus départementaux
les élus régionaux
vous n'imaginez pas à quel point ils
sont la source de ce qui fait vivre
aujourd'hui notre démocratie qui tient
encore par le terrain et non pas par le
haut parce que dans les fractures qui
traversent notre société
ils sont tous les jours au contact de
ces territoires français pour
reconstruire le lien social pour faire
en sorte que la déchirure ne s'aggrave
pas que se retissent petit à petit ce
qui a été abîmée et je crois que nous
pouvons leur dire de tout coeur
un immense merci leur dire notre
reconnaissance pour tout le travail
qu'ils font c'est la force de cette
famille politique c'est la force de
notre famille que d'être ainsi enraciné
partout en france est de contribuer
partout en france à faire vivre notre
démocratie comme nos parlementaires font
vivre nos libertés dans la difficulté de
ces débats que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et je voudrais que nous
puissions leur dire ensemble tous ce
soir notre reconnaissance et notre
gratitude
je voudrais remercier celui qui celui
qui m'a fait confiance pour porter cette
liste et dire ma reconnaissance à
laurent depuis maintenant trois mois
nous faisons campagne ensemble tous les
jours et tous les jours je sens la force
de cette confiance et de ce lien qui
s'est tissée et je veux dire que j'en
suis toujours autant même après trois
mois de campagne le premier impressionné
merci à toi nadine de ton soutien de ta
confiance de cette générosité avec
laquelle tu m'a accueilli tu rappelait
ce rendez vous que nous avons eues il y
a quelques mois je sens bien tu l'as dit
que quand je poussais la porte de ton
bureau tu te demandais surtout qu'est-ce
que ce philosophe vient dans une
affaire de professionnels
g j'ai essayé de te rassurer en se
disant que je ne me sentais pas tout à
fait philosophe simplement professeur de
philosophie que comme professeur je
vivais sur le terrain aussi la réalité
de cette crise que notre pays traverse
que j'étais d'abord un élu local qui est
très modestement tente aujourd'hui
d'apporter dans cette campagne
européenne la voix de ses élus qui
partout en france
vive la crise que nous traversons et les
aspirations que nous partageons et
j'espère que jeter un peu rassuré en
tous les cas
en tous les cas tes conseils m'ont
toujours été précieux et si aujourd'hui
dans cette campagne nous avançons si
unis eh bien c'est la clé de la
dynamique qui nous porte et de cet élan
qui nous pousse si nous avançons si unis
avec toute une équipe formidable et je
voudrais dire ma reconnaissance à tous
nos colistiers qui sont ici nathalie
j'ai été très touchée par des mots mais
je voudrais dire que cette chance
immense que tu évoquais elle est d'abord
et surtout la mienne c'est une chance
pour moi de pouvoir compter sur toi de
pouvoir compter sur vous de pouvoir
compter sur arnaud avec lequel nous
faisons campagne depuis le début de
cette de cet engagement avec fadi avec
brigitte qui sont ici également avec
tous les policiers qui nous ont rejoints
ce qui nous porte aujourd'hui c'est la
force de cette unité
la force de cette union de la droite et
du centre que tu incarnes sur notre
liste
la force de cette alliance avec laurent
hervé et la force d'une parole claire et
d'une parole qui ne tolère aucune
ambiguïté aucune contradiction aucune
incohérence
aucun de ces en même temps facile qui
font le succès d'un marketing électoral
mais qui prépare les déceptions de la
politique menée lorsqu'il est temps
d'entrer dans l'action et de prendre des
décisions
car oui c'est vrai nous n'avons plus le
droit à l'indécision
il faut absolument que nous puissions
refonder l'europe
si nous voulons la sauver je le dis
depuis le début de cette campagne et
nous l'avons vécu bien sûr ici
directement à pont-à-mousson
depuis le début de cette campagne je
vois partout en france s'est levé cette
défiance envers la politique envers la
démocratie parfois envers l'europe en
tous les cas une europe perçu comme trop
lointaines comme trop distante une
europe qui je l'entendais hier à
charleville mézières dans les ardennes
une europe qui a laissé derrière elle
parfois tant de fragilité tant de
difficultés tant d'épreuves
il y a aujourd'hui en europe il y à
aujourd'hui en france tant de gens qui
ont vécu dans leur vie dans leur chair
ce que signifiait la
désindustrialisation ce que signifiait
la disparition progressive de nos
entreprises et de nos emplois eh bien je
crois qu'il faut absolument que nous
puissions refonder l'europe car nous
croyons que l'europe est plus nécessaire
qu'elle ne l'a jamais été
nous croyons à cette europe qui a été
fondée par de grandes figures de notre
famille politique et à laquelle nous
adhérons de tout notre coeur de toute
notre âme nous croyons que l'europe est
nécessaire pour nous renforcer dans ce
monde inquiétant qui se dessine autour
de nous mais que pour qu'elles puissent
nous renforcer il faut d'abord la
refonder il faut prendre les décisions
qui s'imposent il faut sortir de la
naïveté sortir de la naïveté par exemple
dans la compétition économique et
commerciale vous l'avez évoqué ensemble
les rendez vous médiatique que je devais
honoré m'ont empêché d'être présent à
cette rencontre avec l'intersyndicale de
pont-à-mousson de saint-gobain
mais je sais à quel point bien sûr les
inquiétudes existent encore pourquoi et
bien parce que nous avons laissé nos
entreprises exposées à la concurrence de
toutes les régions du monde qui ne
respectent pas les règles que nous nous
fixons à nous-mêmes nous ne pouvons pas
leur en vouloir
mais nous devons regarder avec
pragmatisme à quoi ressemble ce monde
dans lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui
avec arnaud nous avons beaucoup parlé de
cette question depuis le début de cette
campagne et ça a été une immense chance
de pouvoir partager grâce à lui
l'expérience accumulée la compétence
incroyable qu'il a sur tous les sujets
qui engagent l'avenir de l'europe
j'ai beaucoup appris de lui et si
parfois je le dis souvent mais je le
répète encore ce soir puisqu'il est là
devant moi c'est un peu douloureux pour
nous de devoir se séparer pour cette
dernière ligne droite de campagne
après avoir été si proches au cours des
trois derniers mois parfois vous savez
la politique à l'occasion de
compétitions entre les individus mais
parfois elle est aussi l'occasion de
nouer des liens d'amitié qui unissent
les personnes autour d'une cause commune
et c'est ce que nous avons vécu avec
annie et c'est avec arnaud arnaud m'a
appris donc qu'au parlement européen
certains croient encore par exemple dans
le groupe des libéraux que veut
rejoindre monsieur macron certains
croient encore que l'avenir du monde
c'est l'ouverture absolue et qu' il
suffit d'attendre que toutes les
barrières s'abaisse que toutes les
frontières se dit lui que les intérêts
particuliers cesse de s'exprimer et que
la figure du citoyen préoccuper de
l'avenir de son pays soit petit à petit
remplacer par la figure du consommateur
auquel une concurrence universel
apportera à le meilleur produit au
moindre coût eh bien ça ne se passe pas
du tout comme ça les intérêts n'ont pas
disparu la chine joue sa partition
l'amérique joue sa partition et nous
sommes peut-être les seuls en europe à
continuer de croire à cette ouverture
sans réciprocité
nous sommes peut être les derniers à
croire à cette naïveté comme s'il
fallait montrer l'exemple pour que les
autres nous imitent il y a encore en
europe dans ce groupe des libéraux par
exemple des gens qui pensent que par
principe il faut maintenir cette
ouverture
le saviez-vous en europe les marchés
publics constituent 20 % de notre pib
et bien nos marchés publics sont ouverts
à 95% aux acteurs internationaux alors
que les autres acteurs dans le monde
ferment leurs marchés publics les états
unis ouvrent leurs marchés publics qu'à
30%
la russie à 0% la chine à 0% ce qui veut
dire qu'une entreprise chinoise et
comment le comprendre
une entreprise chinoise peut venir
prendre un marché public en france et
faire du profit en france alors que
jamais une entreprise française même là
compétente même la plus compétitive
jamais une entreprise française ne
pourra prendre un marché public en chine
nous voulons bien joué le jeu de la
compétition
nous sommes ici en lorraine dans une
terre qui sait ce qu'est l'excellence
française dans une terre qui sait ce que
sont les savoir faire industriel que
nous sommes capables de produire dans
une terre qui sait que nous sommes
capables de contribuer à écrire
l'histoire du monde mais nous sommes ici
en lorraine dans une terre qui a trop
longtemps subi cette naïveté et nous
avons à exiger désormais tu l'as dit
nadine cette réciprocité de tous ceux
qui voudront échanger avec nous nous
voulons bien joué le jeu de la
compétition et de la concurrence et nous
croyons que nous sommes capables de
rayonner dans le monde
mais encore faut-il que cette
concurrence et cette compétition se
fasse à règles légales et que chacun
accepte de jouer avec les mêmes règles
du jeu car sinon c'est le principe même
de cette liberté qui se trouve
profondément discrédité et nous croyons
à la liberté et nous ne voulons pas
l'avoir discrédité comme elle l'est
parfois aujourd'hui au fond ce qui est
en jeu dans le fait de sortir de cette
naïveté c'est peut-être aussi et je
voudrais partager avec vous cette
réflexion singulièrement ce soir ici
dans cette terre où le travail a un sens
c'est peut-être le fait que nous avons
probablement un peu perdu le sens du
travail le sens du travail c'est à dire
le sens de ce que le travail représente
dans une vie humaine
au fond en europe aujourd'hui nous
n'avons plus de stratégie industrielle
nous avons une doctrine de la
concurrence cette doctrine de la
concurrence elle a pour but essentiel
d'apporter aux consommateurs le meilleur
service possible mais nous ne sommes pas
que des consommateurs et on l'a vu
récemment avec le rapprochement d'alstom
et de siemens qui a été empêché par le
droit européen par la commission
européenne
on l'a vu il y a là une forme de dogme
de la concurrence à tout prix qui va
fragiliser nos entreprises au lieu de
les renforcer
alstom est si mince doivent faire face à
une concurrence venue d'autres régions
du monde
ils doivent faire face à des géants qui
sont en situation de monopole dans leurs
états respectifs et qui sont largement
soutenues par des aides publiques dans
leurs états respectifs ce que nous nous
interdisons à nous mêmes ces entreprises
européennes ont besoin de se renforcer
de se consolider l'une par l'autre et
nous leur interdisons pourquoi parce que
nous croyons qu'il faut continuer
d'apporter aux consommateurs
le produit le moins cher possible mais
nous ne sommes pas que des consommateurs
on a trop longtemps en europe
privilégiez le consommateur au détriment
du travailleur on a trop longtemps en
europe et en france en particulier
disons le privilégier la consommation au
détriment de la production et ainsi on a
perdu le sens du travail et on ne parle
plus du travail que pour parler de la
pénibilité on ne parle plus du travail
que pour parler de la limitation du
temps de travail
on ne parle plus du travail que comme
s'il était une entrave à la consommation
future comme si ceux qui comptaient dans
la vie c'est simplement de pouvoir
consommer le plus possible au moindre
coût nous avons fragiliser nos
entreprises parce que nous avons perdu
le sens du travail est depuis le début
de cette campagne avec laurent nous
l'avons souvent partagé partout en
france
nous entendons cette double inquiétude
s'exprime et l'inquiétude d'un chômage
de masse qui fracturent notre société
depuis trop longtemps maintenant et
simultanément le fait de rencontrer tant
de français de chefs d'entreprises
d'artisans de commerçants qui me disent
qu'ils nous disent
le premier problème que j'ai c'est que
je n'arrive pas à recruter
la première chose qui m'empêche de
travailler
c'est que je n'arrive pas à trouver les
bras les mains les talents les
compétences l'énergie l'envi qui nous
permettrait de continuer à inventer
l'histoire de notre activité de notre
entreprise de servir nos clients et
d'aller partout faire valoir la force de
le savoir faire comment se fait-il que
dans notre pays on est perdu le sens du
travail au point de vivre dans cette
société où tant de français qui
travaillaient qui se donnent de la peine
n'arrive pas à s'en sortir parce qu'une
fiscalité étouffante asphyxie ce qui
crée ceux qui innovent ceux qui
travaillent ceux qui cultivent
comment se fait-il qu'on ait pu perdre
le sens du travail au point que on peut
travailler sans arriver à vivre
dignement de son travail on peut
travailler sans se sentir fier du
travail que l'on fait j'ai créé dans ma
ville un événement sur l'emploi et j'ai
croisé cette année un jeune qui revenait
après être venu l'an dernier il avait
trouvé un travail dans cet événement que
j'organise que nous organisons depuis
maintenant plus de huit ans et il m'a
dit je gagne moins depuis que j'ai
repris un travail qu'avant que je me
mette à reprendre ce travail commence
est il que nous ayons construit cette
société dans laquelle au fond le travail
n'est plus récompensé ni par la
rémunération par la qualité de vie qu'on
doit pouvoir en tirer par la capacité de
faire vivre sa famille son foyer de
transmettre à ses enfants ni non plus
par la fierté qu'on devrait pouvoir en
tirer
ce soir je me suis dit une fois n'est
pas coutume je vais faire un peu le
professeur de philosophie
je me suis dit une fois n'est pas
coutume que je voulais partager avec
vous quelques lignes
quelques lignes d'un texte qui m'a
toujours profondément marqué par ce
qu'il dit peut-être déjà la mort de
cette crise que nous vivons aujourd'hui
c'est un texte de peggy tiré d'un livre
qui s'appelle l'argent peggy qui donne à
sa vie pour la liberté de la france dans
la première guerre mondiale qui a si
durement touchée ce département de
lorraine le croire at on écrit peggy le
croire à ton nous avons été nourris dans
un peuple gay dans ce temps là un
chantier était un lieu de la terre où
les hommes chantait de mon temps tout le
monde chantait dans la plupart des corps
de métiers ont chanté dans ce temps là
on ne gagne est pour ainsi dire rien on
ne gagnait rien on ne dépensait rien et
tout le monde vivait bien
il y avait un honneur incroyable du
travail le plus beau de tous les
honneurs
le plus vrai de tous les honneurs
le seul peut-être qu'ils se tiennent
debout nous avons connu un honneur du
travail exactement le même que celui qui
au moyen-âge régissaient la main et le
coeur
c'était le même honneur conserver intact
en dessous nous avons connu ce soit en
pousser jusqu'à la perfection égal dans
l'ensemble égal dans le plus infimes
détails
nous avons connu cette piété de l'
ouvrage bien fait pousser jusqu'à ses
plus extrême exigence
j'ai vu toute mon enfance écrit pegi qui
venait d'une famille modeste d'une
famille d'artisans et de paysans j'ai vu
toute mon enfance en paille et des
chaises j'ai vu toute mon enfance rang
payet des chaises exactement du même
esprit et du même coeur et de la même
main que ce même peuple avait taillé ses
cathédrales
dans ce bel honneur du métier converger
tous les plus beaux tous les plus nobles
sentiments une dignité et une fierté ne
jamais rien demandé à personne disait-il
voilà donc l idée nous avons été élevés
car demander du travail se mettaient pas
demandé c'était se mettre à sa place
dans un atelier
c'était dans une cité laborieuse se
mettre tranquillement à la place du
travail qui vous attendait un ouvrier ne
savais pas ce que c'était que quémander
ces ouvriers ne servait pas il
travaillait il avait un honneur absolue
comme c'est le propre d'un honneur il
fallait qu'un bâton de chaise fut bien
fait c'était entendu c'était un principe
il ne fallait pas qu'il fût bien fait
pour le salaire ou moyennant le salaire
pour le patron il ne fallait pas qu'il
fût bien fait pour le client il fallait
qu'il fut bien fait en lui même pour lui
même une tradition venue
une tradition venue montée du plus
profond de ce peuple
une histoire un absolu un honneur
voulait qu'un bâton de chaise fut bien
fait tout parti dans la chaise qui ne se
voyait pas était exactement aussi
parfaitement fait que ce qu'on voyait
c'est le principe même des cathédrales
nous avons visité tout à l'heure avec
laurent cette cathédrale de reims
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est la journée de
l'europe et que cette cathédrale sans
doute détruite par cette première guerre
mondiale et restaurer et sur laquelle
s'est fondée la réconciliation du peuple
français et allemand cette cathédrale
était sans doute le meilleur symbole de
l'europe est bien dans les cathédrales
il y as exactement cet honneur du
travail bien fait qui fait que la plus
petite partie et même celles qui ne se
voit pas est fait avec le même coeur le
même esprit et la même main que celle
qui se voit le plus eh bien je crois que
retrouver ce sens du travail
c'est aussi un défi européen
c'est un défi européen car si nous avons
à sortir de la naïveté dans la
mondialisation c'est pour pouvoir garder
la capacité de travailler en europe pour
pouvoir retrouver la capacité de
produire ce que nous consommons la
capacité de produire ce que nous
consommons depuis trop longtemps
maintenant notre pays est en déficit
commercial est derrière cette expression
compliqué il y à une simple réalité
chaque année nous consommons plus que
nous reproduisons ce qui veut dire que
chaque année au fond notre économie se
laisse peu à peu racheté et tu l'as dit
nadine très concrètement avoir perdu ce
sens du travail avoir perdu cette valeur
du travail
c'est exactement cela qui nous conduit à
voir aujourd'hui partir des fleurons
dans les bras d'autres acteurs qui eux
pour le coup ne nous attendent pas eh
bien nous avons enfin à sortir de la
naïveté à nous retrousser les manches et
à faire enfin de l'europe un lieu où on
défende nos entreprises et nos emplois
il faut ne plus avoir en europe qu'une
doctrine de la concurrence il faut avoir
en europe une stratégie pour notre
avenir
une stratégie industrielle une stratégie
commerciale nous avons des atouts pour
cela et ils sont européens
notre premier à
tous dans la mondialisation c'est
d'abord ce marché commun c'est ce marché
unique que nous avons su construire
c'est ce marché qui peut être une force
inestimable pour pouvoir faire entendre
notre voix faire peser nos intérêts dans
la compétition mondiale
ce que vivent aujourd'hui
douloureusement les britanniques ce vers
quoi vous hante voudrait nous entraîner
ceux qui se sont félicités du bric site
c'est cette solitude du peuple anglais
qui aujourd'hui peinent à obtenir des
accords de la part de ses partenaires
commerciaux
même les etats-unis qui avaient regardé
d'un oeil bienveillant ce break site des
anglo saxons
même les états unis regardent
aujourd'hui les britanniques en disant
avec vous on verra après on commercera
avec vous si vous respectez nos règles
alors que même les états unis ne peuvent
pas se passer du marché européen
ce marché de 500 millions d'habitants
quand vous êtes quelques dizaines de
millions d'habitants
une grande puissance peut vous
contournez quand vous êtes plusieurs
centaines de millions d'habitants
personne dans le monde ne peut vous
contourner notre marché peut devenir un
grand outil politique il peut devenir un
grand levier pour défendre nos
entreprises et nos emplois
encore faut-il que nous vivions dans une
europe qui assume de défendre ses
intérêts qui assume de sortir de la
naïveté qui assume qu'elle est c'est
vrai un lieu qui a des ressources à
protéger qui a des savoir-faire à
préserver parce qu'elle veut les faire
encore rayonner longtemps dans
l'histoire et dans le monde et c'est
l'un des enjeux de ce défi européen
redonner un équilibre à la
mondialisation sortir de cette
mondialisation devenue folle où nous
avons pendant trop longtemps cru que
toute l'industrie pouvait se faire en
asie et que nous allons devenir une
terre de services et de loisirs sortir
de cette mondialisation devenue folle
qui disons le très simplement a produit
une grande part de la crise écologique
que nous traversons on le sait ici dans
cette terre industrielle
nous avons aujourd'hui en france parmi
les plus belles forêts du monde et bien
le saviez vous nous envoyons nos chaînes
être traités en chine pour devenir du
parquet et revenir en france pour
pouvoir meubler nos appartements et nos
maisons
le parquet qui vient chez nous les
meubles qui reviennent chez nous on
franchit des milliers de kilomètres
avant de revenir chez nous il
ont poussé sous forme d'arbre dans nos
propres forêt française et il a fallu
qu'ils aillent en chine parce que nous
n'avons plus assez d'industrie pour les
traiter ici en france ils ont fait des
milliers de kilomètres avant d'arriver
chez nous et ensuite on explique aux
salariés français qui a besoin de sa
voiture pour faire 10 km pour aller
travailler que c'est lui qui est
responsable de la crise climatique et
que c'est lui qui va payer
et on explique en passant et en
expliquant pas sans qu'on va lui
supprimer sa voiture puisque c'est le
programme dans marche les voitures à
essence doivent disparaître dans les
années qui viendront alors que je vois
qu'aujourd'hui même un grand producteur
de voitures électriques annonce qu' il y
à une pénurie de matériaux pour
fabriquer des batteries et que à grand
renfort de stratégie électrique on
provoque la crise écologique qu'on
espérait éviter
bref vous irez tous travaillé en
trottinette électrique et le monde sera
plus beau en tous les cas
évidemment nous nous préoccupons de la
crise écologique
évidemment nous nous préoccupons de
transmettre à nos enfants un monde qui
soit encore vivable mais si nous devons
nous préoccuper de la crise écologique
alors il faut remonter à sa cause
il faut remonter à sa matrice et quelle
est la cause de la crise écologique
sinon cette mondialisation débridée
cette mondialisation sans frein que nous
avons laissé se faire et qui nous a
dépossédé de notre capacité de produire
et de créer ce que nous consommons et
qui ainsi a créé ce monde de flux
perpétuels ce monde de mouvement
perpétuel qui déstabilise le monde qui
déstabilise nos sociétés et qui
déstabilise la nature elle-même redonner
un équilibre à la mondialisation en
assumant de défendre nos intérêts pour
que nous puissions devenir ce nouveau
poumon dans le monde a besoin en
assumant que nous avons à jouer ce rôle
car l'europe a souvent écrit l'histoire
du monde parfois pour le pire et parfois
souvent pour le meilleur et bien nous
avons à redonner un équilibre à cette
mondialisation qui se fait aujourd'hui
sans nous qui se fait aujourd'hui sans
que nous puissions maîtriser quoi que ce
soit pour faire en sorte que le monde de
demain retrouve une stabilité et pour
remédier à ce défi écologique en même
temps qu'au défi social et économique
devant lequel nous sommes placés
redonner un équilibre à la
mondialisation c'est aussi et je sais
que c'est une préoccupation que nous
partageons bien sûr mettre fin à notre
impuissance face aux flux migratoires
car la crise migratoire elle est l'enjeu
fondamental pour l'équilibré du monde
qui vient je suis frappée depuis le
début de ces débats d'entendre beaucoup
de commentateurs parfois le
contradicteur m'opposer que la crise
migratoire serait finie on me dit ah
mais attendez
et vous parlez beaucoup d'immigration
mais enfin quand même tout ça est un peu
ridicule la crise migratoire c'était en
2015 mais maintenant c'est fini
eh bien non disons nous le savons bien
disons le simplement entre nous la crise
migratoire n'a pas encore commencé elle
n'a pas encore commencé parce que
l'explosion de la démographie sur le
continent africain fait que si nous ne
savons pas remédié à l'impuissance que
nous avons aujourd'hui entre tenues trop
longtemps si nous ne savons pas
maîtriser nos frontières nous allons
continuer de produire du malheur à
grande échelle malheur pour nos sociétés
déjà a profondément déstabilisé par une
immigration massive que nous n'avons pas
su intégrer
c'est un ancien ministre de l'intérieur
socialiste qui nous a averti aujourd'hui
nous vivons côte à côte demain peut-être
nous serons face à face on ne peut pas
ne rien faire d'un avertissement comme
celui-ci malheur pour nos sociétés
parce que l'impuissance d'aujourd'hui
est le ferment détention de demain
mais malheur aussi pour tous ces jeunes
venus d'afrique auquel par notre
impuissance
nous laissons espérer le miroir aux
alouettes d'un eldorado qu'ils ne
trouveront pas s'ils parviennent en
europe
malheureux pour tous ces jeunes auxquels
des passeurs sans scrupules font croire
que la prospérité consiste à traverser
la méditerranée
alors que traverser la méditerranée de
le conduira qu'à une impasse et nous en
avons parlé ensemble nadine de tous ces
jeunes qui parfois mineures avec le
soutien massif de nos conseils
départementaux sont ici loger mais qui
vivent dans une situation à la fois
infiniment coûteuse pour nos dépenses
publiques et en même temps infiniment
malheureuse pour chacun d'entre eux je
n'envie pas leur sort mais je serai le
dernier à dire du mal de tous ces jeunes
ils sont d'abord les victimes de cette
impuissance que nous avons laissé trop
longtemps prospéré
oui nous devons maîtriser nos frontières
c'est la condition de toute générosité
nous devons maîtriser nos frontières ce
sera le premier acte de notre humanité
et comme tu le disais à l'instant
à tout ce nous font de grandes leçons de
morale en nous disant que parler des
frontières c'est se fermer au reste du
monde
à tous ceux qui nous font de grandes
leçons de générosité proposons de venir
faire un tour porte de la chapelle
proposant de venir faire un tour est
calé demandant leur si vraiment ceci
ressemble à de la solidarité
si ceci ressemble à de l'humanité non
c'est une impasse donc oui il faut
maîtriser nos frontières et le défi est
devant nous l'a encore et c'est un défi
européen nous le croyons profondément
face à un défi de cette ampleur il faut
une action européenne forte
j'étais il ya quelques jours en grèce et
en grèce comme tu l'as vu toi aussi
laurent en allant directement sur ces
îles grecques qui sont à quelques
kilomètres des côtes de la turquie en
grèce on voit parfaitement à quel point
il est nécessaire que l'europe se
renforce pour soutenir chacun de nos
pays pour faire face à ce défi nous ne
croyons pas contrairement au
rassemblement national que nous serons
plus forts tout seul
nous ne sommes pas des idéologues nous
ne croyons pas qu'il suffise de dire que
l'europe c'est forcément mauvais et de
voter contre
comme ils l'ont fait au cours des
dernières années tout ce qui pouvait
nous permettre de nous renforcer face au
défi migratoire
le rassemblement national a voté contre
l'établissement de contrôles
systématiques à l'entrée dans l'espace
schengen le rassemblement national à
voter contre le renforcement de frontex
cette agence européenne qui lutte contre
l'immigration illégale
le rassemblement national a voté contre
le fichier qui permet de savoir qui
volent dans le ciel européen est bien le
rassemblement national nous le disons a
pris une lourde responsabilité celle de
fragiliser nos pays face à la crise
migratoire mais nous ne croyons pas non
plus à la solution proposée par emmanuel
macron je ne sais pas si vous l'avez vu
mais la ministre de la justice madame
bello b a dit aujourd'hui sur bfm tv
n'ayant aucune illusion on n'arrêtera
pas les flux migratoires l'immigration
on ne l'arrêtera pas ce que pense
monsieur macron et son gouvernement
c'est que les flux migratoires sont une
fatalité et que la seule chose à faire
consiste à se répartir les quotas de
migrants qui sont arrivés illégalement
sur le sol européen
comme si la solution consistait
gérer notre impuissance eh bien nous
nous voulons mettre fin à notre
impuissance et nous disons que le
premier devoir de toute construction
politique c'est de maîtriser ses
frontières et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous défendons le principe
d'une double frontières nous voulons
défendre ensemble les frontières de
l'europe en faisant en sorte que ces
frontières et laurent vous en reparlera
soit vraiment défendu par des principes
clairs et fort faire en sorte que jamais
le fait d'arriver illégalement sur le
sol européen ne vous garantissent que
vous pourrez rester longtemps sur le sol
européen
tant que nous n'aurons pas mis fin à
cette équation il y aura encore des
morts en mer méditerranée
la seule manière de tuer les réseaux de
passeurs c'est bien sûr de mener une
action policière et judiciaire forte et
nous avons partagé une soirée entière
avec frédéric péchenard l'un de nos
colistiers et arnaud sur ce sujet mais
la seule manière à la fin de supprimer
ces réseaux de passeurs c'est de faire
en sorte que l'on n'ait aucune chance de
rester durablement sur le sol européen
si on est entrés illégalement sur le sol
européen
le jour où on aura établi cette
certitude alors il n'y aura plus un seul
mort en méditerranée
il n'y aura plus un seul passeur qui
pourra faire son travail scandaleux et
hymne
il faut défendre ensemble les frontières
extérieures de l'europe et simultanément
nous voulons que chaque pays conserve la
maîtrise de sa politique migratoire et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
parlons de double frontières
rassurez-vous bien sûr il y a aussi
beaucoup de frontaliers qui traverse
tous les jours la frontière pour aller
travailler de l'autre côté nous voulons
pas évidemment sortir de l'espace
schengen et de cette libre circulation
qui est l'un des atouts les plus
magnifiques que l'europe ait su
construire mais nous voulons que les
états puissent garder la possibilité qui
leur est offerte aujourd'hui
temporairement
nous voulons qu'ils puissent la garder
durablement la possibilité de faire des
contrôles ciblés à leurs frontières
lorsqu'une crise l'exigent lorsqu'une
situation l'obligent pour faire en sorte
qu effectivement en cas de difficultés
nous n'ayons pas à subir le fait que des
gens qui ont pu rentrer illégalement sur
le sol européen
notre aussi sur le sol français c'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui déjà depuis de
longs mois à la frontière franco
italienne est bien le fait que cette
dérogation existe n'a empêché personne
d'aller faire son travail de frontaliers
de l'autre côté de la frontière
le principe de cette double frontières
c'est le principe d'une maîtrise
national de nos politiques migratoires
parce que c'est une question de principe
précisément nous ne croyons pas à une
europe qui nous déposséderait de notre
souveraineté démocratique et nous
croyons que le rap est là pour renforcer
nos pays et non pas pour prendre sur
elle la responsabilité des décisions que
nous sommes responsables de prendre
nous croyons à ce grand principe
européen qu'est la subsidiarité qui veut
que la meilleure décision c'est celle
qui se prend au plus près du terrain et
nous voulons que demain les élus que
nous avons choisie pour incarner notre
souveraineté nationale que nos
parlementaires puissent dire ce que nous
sommes capables d'accueillir en fonction
de nos capacités d'intégration une
europe qui se contenterait comme le
propose monsieur marc-andré partir des
quotas de migrants une europe qui
voudraient comme le dit monsieur macron
exclure de l'espace schengen les pays
qu'ils n'accepteront pas de recevoir des
quotas de migrants c'est une europe qui
sera durablement discrédité et une
europe qui donnera le sentiment aux
peuples européens qu'elle se construit
contre malgré eux contre leur volonté
cette europe là nous n'en voulons pas
vous le voyez l'opposition n'est pas
entre populisme et progressisme c'est
l'europe que propose monsieur mâcon qui
je le crois et je le regrette alimente
celle de madame le pen c'est l'europe
qui voudrait devenir un super état à la
place de nos états qui fait que la
défiance montant vers le projet européen
alors que sa signification profonde a
toujours été de renforcer
chacun de nos pays de renforcer ce que
nous sommes parce que c'est au fond de
ce que nous sommes qu'il s'agit l'europe
n'est pas d'abord un projet elle se
fonde sur une histoire
elle se fonde sur un élan magnifique
cette cathédrale de reims détruite par
la guerre
restaurée est le symbole de cette europe
qui vit la réconciliation de la france
et de l'allemagne qui vit la
réconciliation des peuples européens
parce que ces peuples européens étaient
déjà liés entre eux par une civilisation
commune et que la guerre qu'ils se sont
fait pendant trop longtemps était une
guerre fratricide
nous sommes liés les uns aux autres par
un héritage qui nous précèdent
l'europe n'est pas d'abord un projet
l'europe ce n'est pas d'abord des normes
des règles des traités
l'europe c'est d'abord une civilisation
un héritage en partage l'europe c'est
d'abord des racines et ses racines oui
c'est vrai reconnaissons le peut-être le
coeur de notre crise se trouve dans le
fait que nous n'avons pas su les nommer
toutes les civilisations sont mortelles
nous disait paul valéry
mais une civilisation ne meurt jamais
d'avoir été attaqué par ses concurrents
ou par ses ennemis
une civilisation disparaît toujours
parce qu'elle s'est oublié elles mêmes
et c'est sans doute
reconnaissant le ce qui était en train
d'arriver à l'europe
nommé nos racines dire qui nous sommes
et bien c'est la condition pour relever
le grand défi qui est devant nous ce
grand défi de la lutte contre tous qui
fragmentent notre société aujourd'hui la
france est en train de devenir dit un
livre récent publié par jérôme fourquet
la france est en train de devenir un
archipel de communauté qui s'éloignent
les unes des autres qui ne se
reconnaissent pas de lien commun la
france sous l'effet de cette immigration
massive que nous n'avons pas su intégrer
je le disais mais la france aussi sous
l'effet de cet oubli de nous mêmes sous
l'effet de notre incapacité à
transmettre aux générations qui viennent
le sens de ce que nous sommes le sens
d'une culture partagée
la france est en train de devenir un
archipel de communauté qui finissent par
signoret les unes les autres et c'est ce
qui nourrit exactement les
communautarismes
c'est ce qui nourrit la radicalisation
c'est ce qui nourrit l'islamisme c'est
ce qui alimente le terrorisme qui a
tenté tant de jeunes qui étaient nés en
france auquel nous n'avons pas su dire
ce que voulait dire être français auquel
nous n'avons pas su dire ce qu'exigeait
d'être fils de cette europe de cette
civilisation héritiers de cette histoire
continuateur de cet élan je le crois
profondément
face à l'islamisme évidemment il faut
des réponses judiciaires sans faille
il faut des réponses policières
absolument radicales mais il faut aussi
que nous puissions remporter cette
grande bataille
la mère de toutes les batailles la
bataille de l'éducation la bataille de
la transmission
citant deux jeunes citant deux jeunes
dont certains d'ailleurs n'étaient pas
issus de l'immigration se sont laissés
tenter par la folie du djihadisme c'est
d'abord parce que l'islamisme
aujourd'hui dans tant de nos quartiers
d'entendre nos banlieues rempli le vide
que nous avons laissé derrière nous et
qu'ils prospèrent sur cet oubli
parce qu'à beaucoup de ces jeunes nous
n'avons pas su donner quelque chose à
aimer
nous n'avons pas su donner la français
mais nous n'avons pas su donner l'europe
en héritage parce que nous n'avons pas
su nommer nos racines
en 2004 nous avons refusé de dire dans
nos traités fondateurs dans ce projet de
constitution
nous avons refusé de dire ce qu étaient
les racines de l'europe ses racines
grecques qui ont fait ce miracle de la
raison qui veut que dans nos cités ont
choisi de ne pas seulement s'en tenir
aux mythes mais qu'on veut délibéré
qu'on veut cette rationalité et cette
raison critique qui du logos de la
pensée fait un dialogos un dialogue
le miracle de la vie démocratique qui se
vit aujourd'hui dans notre vie
parlementaire comme dans chacun de nos
conseils municipaux il est né de cet
esprit grec directement il est fils de
l'europe c'est aussi bien sûr le sens de
l'égalité de tous devant la respublica
devant la chose commune qui prospère par
l' empire romain qui se développe dans
tout le monde latin et c'est pourquoi
avoir tant tardé à le dire pourquoi
n'avoir pas su les nommer ses racines
chrétiennes de l'europe qui ont fait de
nous ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui on
peut ne pas être chrétien et le savoir
parfaitement
on peut ne pas être chrétien et avoir le
coeur retourné quand on regarde notre
dame de paris brûle et on peut ne pas
être chrétien et être émerveillé en
entrant dans notre dame de reims on peut
on peut ne pas être chrétien on peut
même être anticlérical on peut être
hostile à la foi chrétienne
on peut être communiste comme l'était
aragon et reconnaître que le champ de la
france a été portée plus haut que jamais
par une jeune fille de lorraine qui
s'appelait jeanne d'arc
aragon qui ragon qui écrivait que les
pages du procès de jeanne d'arc étaient
les plus belles pages de toute
l'histoire de la littérature et bien ses
plus belles pages de toute l'histoire de
la littérature par leur simplicité par
la beauté de ses réponses qui confondait
des jugent inique ses plus belles pages
de la littérature par l'innocence qui
transparaît dans les mots de cette jeune
fille de 17 ans qui fait face à ses
persécuteurs ses plus belles pages de la
littérature française elles sont nées
précisément ici en lorraine
elles sont nées de cette simplicité et
on peut les reconnaître
elles disent au fond le cri de révolte
contre toute injustice et elles peuvent
être partagées infiniment par tous ceux
qui se reconnaissent dans ses racines de
l'europe par tous ceux qui même en ne
les partageant pas par leur propre
héritage savent pourtant les admirer
nous avons élu un président de la
république qui nous avait dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de culture française
alors que nous sommes le pays n'en n'ont
ne ne sifflait pas au fond je crois
qu'il n'était pas le coupable du mal que
nous connaissons il en était peut-être
seulement le symptôme l'un de ceux qui
depuis trop longtemps portait cet oubli
de nous-mêmes qui a fait la crise que
nous traversons aujourd'hui est bien ici
nous sommes bien placés en lorraine pour
dire que le grand défi qui est devant
nous c'est de savoir dire qui nous
sommes
c'est de savoir redire qu'il nous sommes
à tous ces jeunes qui grandissent en
france je suis tellement heureux de voir
que tant de jeunes sont avec nous ce
soir pour partager ce grand défi de
savoir dire qui nous sommes
le savoir redire qui nous sommes parce
que c'est ici en lorraine pendant la
signature du traité de verdun en 843 qui
a été nommé pour la première fois ce
beau mot de français qui allait devenir
la france c'est ici que la france n et
c'est ici que la france pour la première
fois a été nommé et bien c'est ici aussi
sans doute qu'il faut pouvoir de nouveau
repartir de nouveau recommencer
c'est d'ici qu'il faut refonder l'europe
pour pouvoir rétablir la france c'est
d'ici qu'il faut de nouveau nommé les
racines de l'europe pour pouvoir dire ce
qui fait la france c'est d'ici que
comment cette belle aventure et bien
cette aventure comme vous l'a dit nadine
elle est dans vos mains il nous reste 10
7 jours 17 jours pour vaincre cette
fausse alternative entre l'impuissance
de la colère et le déni de réalité
dix sept jours pour faire entendre le
vrai choix dont nous avons besoin pour
l'europe
dix sept jours et dans 17 jours j'en
suis sûr
cette victoire que nous devons à la
france que nous devons à l'art à
l'europe
cette victoire sera votre victoire c'est
vous qui allez la conquérir tous les
jours sur le terrain il faut convaincre
il faut parler on va tout donner et dans
17 jours nous aurons devant nous ce
grand défi enfin accomplie refonder
l'europe pour rétablir la france merci
infiniment à vous tous
mais dans les faits
[Applaudissements]
ils ont les blancs
on pourrait l'écouter des heures
tellement ce qui dit est intelligent et
visionnaire et avouez que ça nous change
des caricatures grossières de madame le
pen ou du vide de sens des petits pois
macro nist
mes chers amis je n'ai jamais été
socialiste
et je vous rassure ce n'est pas au
programme mais je vais quand même me
référer à la signature de campagne de
françois mitterrand en 1981 pour
qualifier celui que nous allons
accueillir sur scène dans quelques
secondes
une force tranquille une force parce
qu'il est allé chercher sa légitimité
dans les urnes
au moment où nous avions perdu cette
élection présidentielle imperdable et où
tous les autres responsables de la
droite cherchait une bonne excuse pour
ne pas avoir à s'impliquer tranquille
parce que malgré les attaques et malgré
les caricatures il est toujours resté
serein confiant et offensif il a foi en
l'avenir et il s'en donne les moyens
vous pouvez ovationné le président des
républicains
laurent wauquiez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
grand merci à tous
[Musique]
merci à tous vous savez ce qui me touche
le plus quand on entre avec
françois-xavier avec tous les amis dans
nos salles les unes après les autres
c'est de sentir que vous avez repris de
l'envié de l'enthousiasmé qui à nouveau
de la fierté qui à nouveau de l'énergie
dans notre famille politique et dans
cette campagne
ce qui me touche le plus c'est de
constater que la campagne la famille
politique qui bouscule les cartes celle
qui partant d'un point qui nous était
promis d' apocalypse et de sorties petit
à petit semaine après semaine progresse
la seule liste ou dans cette élection il
se passe quelque chose où il ya une
dynamique
c'est notre liste des républicains de
l'union de la droite et du centre
et je suis fier de ça je suis fier de ça
parce que je vous l'avais promis et
parce que je vous avais promis qu'on
reconstruirait et je suis heureux que
nous soyons capables de le faire en le
faisant ensemble
l'image que j'ai devant moi et l'image
que je veux pour notre famille politique
c'est celle où on à la fois nos mères
cet ancien monde qu'a voulu vilipender
emmanuel macron celui qui n'aime pas
celui de l'enracinement celui de la
fidélité celui de la loyauté celui de
l'esprit de service celui qui est
attachée à la place de nos communes
merci henri avec tous les maires qui
sont ici celui que je vois avec
l'implication de nos départements avec
notamment françois et nicolas qui
incarnent deux beaux départements dans
lesquels on n'a pas oublié ce qui est
aussi la place d'une france rurale qui
sait d'où elle vient et qui ne considère
pas non plus qu'elle à sortir de
l'histoire et qui demandent juste d'être
traités de façon équitable dans un pays
qui n'a pas oublié ce qu'était
l'aménagement du territoire au moment où
on a créé la république nos régions
valérie autour de tout ce que vous
apportez ici dans cette belle région du
grand est et je remercie jean du soutien
qui nous a apporté avec vigueur et
clarté
pour moi c'était très important et je
tiens à dire ici dans cette terre sur
laquelle jean veil aussi et puis enfin
tous nos députés tous nos sénateurs
ceux qui incarnent l'expérience à
l'image de gérard ceux qui incarnent les
nouveaux talents à l'image de fabien nos
sénateurs tous tels qu'ils sont ici
gérard que je remercie de son honnêteté
intellectuelle et de sa présence lui qui
a souvent été une grande figure dans les
batailles de notre famille politique
mais aussi philippe françois daniel
jacques sébastien même qui nous est venu
du val d'oise un jeune sénateur qui est
plein de fougue et qui est venu ici
jusqu'en lorraine pour ce meeting venant
du val d'oise
merci à toi sébastien pourquoi est ce
que j'aime c'est parce que c'est l'image
de cette unité que je voulais nous
rendre parce que je suis convaincu que
au delà de ce mouvement qui est en train
de se passer
il y à un message qui nous est envoyé
dans cette campagne dès le début tout a
été fait pour expliquer aux français que
quoi qu'ils veulent quoi qu'il désire il
n'avait que deux options et qu'ils
étaient enfermés dans cette impasse que
certains avaient écrit à l'avance pour
il n'avait que deux options soit on vote
pour le rassemblement national soit on
vote pour en marche et les français qui
n'aiment pas qu'on leur dicte leur choix
qui est un peuple plus politique que
tous les autres qui aiment la politique
parce que chez nous on aime le débat
n'aime pas que dans une élection on leur
dicte à l'avance ce qu'ils ont le droit
de penser et ce qu'ils n'ont pas le
droit de dire et les français regardent
ce choix en étant à la fois perplexe et
écoeuré ils ne veulent pas voter pour le
rassemblement national parce qu'ils ont
vu le visage de marine le pen
de ce débat du second tour ils ne
veulent pas signer un chèque en blanc
pour marine le pen parce qu'ils savent
trop au fond d'eux-mêmes que cela
pourrait conduire au chaos pour notre
pays gère un vrai mais de l'autre côté
ils ne veulent pas plus donner le
sentiment de cautionner un président de
la république qui les a tellement déçu
une majorité en marge qui les a
tellement écoeuré des allers retours qui
ont fait tant de victimes en si peu de
temps qu'ils ont mis le pays dans un tel
état qui ont malmené les retraités qui
n'ont pas permis de redresser
substantiellement notre pays face à la
menace de l'islamisme qui a sous-estimé
la question de l'immigration et qui n'a
rien fait pour remettre la tête à
l'endroit dans nos dépenses publiques
des français qui savent très bien que
les cadeaux d'aujourd'hui seront les
impôts de demain
parce qu'ils ont un président de la
république et un gouvernement qui n'a
rien fait pour remettre les choses à
l'endroit
eh bien les français ne veulent ni de
l'un ni de l'autre
et il faut dire aux français qu'ils ont
un autre choix
il faut dire aux français qu'il ya une
alternative
il faut dire aux français qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe à droite
il faut dire qu'il ya cette union de la
droite et du centre que nous avons créés
il faut leur dire qu'ils ne sont pas
prisonnier de cette réédition du second
tour de la présidentielle il faut leur
dire qu'ils ont un autre choix possible
que le chaos de marine le pen est la
déception des manuels macron cet autre
choix dans la campagne des européennes
c'est celui que nous leur offrons en
démocratie on a toujours le choix
ne tombez pas dans ce piège des
populistes contre les progressistes il y
à un autre choix pour les français est
dans l'europe
cette question là est encore plus
importante dans l'europe cette question
là est encore plus importante parce que
ces deux visions cette vision
manichéenne à laquelle revient sans
cesse le président de la république est
juste une façon d'enterrer l'avenir de
l'europe parce que les deux sont des
impasses
marine le pen est évidemment une impasse
ici dans cette terre nathalie où tu l'a
rappelé vous avez bien des familles qui
trouvent leur emploi et leur pouvoir
d'achat à travers cette coopération
européenne
ici plus qu'ailleurs vous savez bien que
la déconstruction de l'europe serait une
catastrophe
comment marine le pen ne peut-elle pas
comprendre ce qui se passe comment ne
peut-elle pas voir ce qui se passe de
l'autre côté de la honte de la manche où
le royaume uni va connaître les pires
tourments perdre l'emploi fragiliser le
pouvoir d'achat pourquoi parce qu'ils
ont écouté les mêmes voies que marine le
pen et que cela les a menés dans le mur
marine le pen propose pour la france une
sortie de l'histoire
elle propose la déconstruction de
l'europe elle propose la déconstruction
de l'euro je combats de toutes mes
forces marine le pen dans cette élection
parce qu'en matière européenne je suis
convaincu que c'est un choix
catastrophique pour la france mais de
l'autre côté françois xavier
bien évidemment que ce que propose
emmanuel macron est tout autant une
impasse il ne comprend pas que les
français sont pour une vision européenne
mais qu'ils s'interrogent sur ce que
l'europe est devenue les français
veulent de l'europe parce qu'ils ont
parfaitement compris que seuls nous
n'étions pas assez forte mais ils
veulent que l'on remette l'europe dans
le bon chemin
or aujourd'hui ce que propose emmanuel
macron c'est toujours plus de l'europe
qui ne marchais pas toujours plus de
l'europe qui ne marchaient pas regarder
leurs programmes
nous en parlons ensemble tout à l'heure
la première phrase de la première
proposition de la première idée du
programme dans marche commence par taxer
toutes leurs propositions consiste à
créer des organismes supplémentaire des
institutions supplémentaire d impôt
supplémentaire ils n'ont pas compris que
ce que voulait la france et les
européens
ça n'était pas plus de bureaucratie ils
veulent revenir à l'europe des projets
qui étaient l'europe que nous aimions
ils ne veulent plus de l'europe de la
bureaucratie et des normes qui nous
attends tu affaiblis par le passé et ce
que propose de plus ce que propose de
plus emmanuel macron c'est plus
d'élargissement j'y reviendrai
l'élargissement nous a fait tellement de
mal
voilà un programme proposé par en marche
dans lequel il n'y a pas un mot sur
l'élargissement où ils font tout pour
que l'on ne comprenne pas vraiment ce
qu'ils ont derrière la tête
est ce qu'ils ont derrière la tête je
vous le dis c'est ce qu'a dit emmanuel
macron à trieste
c'est ce qu'il a dit à bucarest il est
pour l'entrée la plus rapide possible de
la roumanie et de la bulgarie dans
l'espace schengen
ce qui est une folie et il est pour
l'entrée très rapide des balkans à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne alors
que ces pays ne sont pas prêts et que
cela n'est pas raisonnable
nous nos positions sont très claires
nous sommes contre tout élargissement
supplémentaire de l'union européenne
parce que cela aboutirait à fragiliser
avec trop de pays différents et dans
tout cela ce qui me fait le plus de
peine c'est qu'il a isolé la france
moi je crois dans l'entente franco
allemande
je crois dans la nécessité profondément
dans ma sphère que l'europe se construit
dans la capacité à mettre les gens sont
ils à mépriser les italiens il a insulté
l'europe centrale
il est allé dans les pays scandinaves en
leur expliquant comment il fallait gérer
leur économie
eux qui lui ont répandu mais n'êtes vous
pas le dernier élève de la classe
n'est ce pas vous qui pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de votre pays avait
le pire déficit budgétaire de la zone
euro
vous qui venez et avaient
l'outrecuidance d'arriver chez nous en
nous donnant des leçons vous feriez
mieux de commencer par nettoyer vos
propres écuries et d'être au moins un
des rares pays européens qui a été
incapable de baisser sa dette au cours
des deux dernières années
et oui nadine il y a quelque chose
d'indécent avoir un gouvernement qui n'a
fait aucune économie et qui a juste pris
en deux ans 6 milliard d'euros dans la
poche des retraités et qu'il ne vous
rendra pas parce que la réalité c'est
qu'en refusant la réévaluation des
retraites cette année
la réalité c'est qu'en ayant pris une
augmentation de csg la réalité c'est
qu'en laissant toute une partie des
retraités continuer à voir
l'augmentation de la csg ce président de
la république a pris 6 milliard d'euros
dans la poste des retraités qu'il ne
leur rend pas et c'est quand même une
supercherie de le voir ensuite quelques
jours avant une élection comme par
hasard envoyer un petit courrier pour
expliquer glorieusement tiens je vais
vous rendre une toute petite partie de
ce que je vous avais pris parce que je
me suis fait rattraper par la patrouille
quelle triste vision de ce qu'est la
politique française
les retraités ne sont pas des
privilégiés ils ont travaillé toute leur
vie pour leur retraite
et oui nadine il ya une époque où la
france n'était pas isolé
cette époque je ne l'oublient pas c'est
celle où la france était la présidence
de l'union européenne
cette époque c'était celle de nicolas
sarkozy est à l'époque la france elle
entraînait dans sa dynamique l'union
européenne
alors nous nous avons une lourde
responsabilité je veux vous parler de
cela pour porter notre étendard
j'ai voulu qu'il y ait un trio est à la
tête de ce trio j'ai souhaité que ce
soit françois xavier qui porte ce choix
et je vous remercie vous qui êtes les
militants de ma famille politique de
m'avoir fait confiance
ce choix n'était pas facile eh bien je
vais vous dire ce que je crois et
n'oublions pas cette leçon en politique
les seuls bons choix sont les choix qui
ne sont pas faciles et soit qu'ils sont
applaudis par les commentateurs ne sont
jamais les bons choix
les seuls choix qui vaille ce sont les
choix de courage maintenant vous savez
pourquoi j'ai voulu françois-xavier
savez quand il ya eu ce débat france
télévisions et qu'on a demandé à chacune
des têtes de listes d'exhiber un objet
symbole de ce qu'il voyait pour l'europe
et que je voyais chaque tête de liste
l'une après l'autre sortir un objet qui
devenait de plus en plus grotesque
je me disais mais comment la politique
française at-elle pu devenir cela vous
alliez la tête de liste du rassemblement
national qui avait sorti une passoire
rouge pour incarner sa vision de
l'europe
vous avez une tête de lit je ne sais
même plus son nom qui avait sorti une
paire de menottes sur laquelle il avait
mis des autocollants jaunes vous aviez
la tête de liste en mars qui avait sorti
du piment d'espelette j'adore le piment
d'espelette mais enfin peut-être que
quand on parle d'europe il ya d'autres
choses à dire et françois-xavier lui a
sorti un livre et qu'elle livre il a
sorti l'iliade d'homère
ce que j'aime chez françois xavier c'est
qu'il remet de la hauteur et qu'il nous
rend notre dignité
c'est cette politique là que j'aime
à ses côtés il ya un trio il y à agnès
il y à arnaud qui est ici qui nous vient
de bourgogne franche comté et qui est le
meilleur spécialiste européen sur toutes
les questions de lutte contre le
terrorisme et toutes les questions
militaires et de défense je suis très
heureux tu arnaud soit à nos côtés et il
y a évidemment celle que je n'ai pas
oublié parce que dès le début je lui dis
qu'elle serait là et que j'avais besoin
d'elle nadine c'est quelqu'un que
j'apprécie énormément et je l'apprécient
pour une raison qui est pour moi la plus
importante c'est qu'elle incarne un
repère dans notre famille politique la
droite n'est la droite que quand elle
n'oublie jamais qu'elle doit veiller sur
chacun avec la même attention
la droite doit veiller sur celui qui
réussit parce qu'elle est fière de celui
qui réussit mais elle doit veiller aussi
sur celui qui appartient aux classes
moyennes modestes qui appartient la
france populaire qui chaque jour à
l'image de cette si belle citation de
paix dit que tu nous as lui fait juste
son travail correctement
parfois en prenant sa voiture et en
allant travailler loin de chez lui
c'est cette droite là gaulliste du
gaullisme social qui sait où elle est à
laquelle appartient nadine morano et
qu'elle incarne dans notre famille
politique
moi j'ai toujours défendues nadine parce
que j'aime la voix qu'elle apporte à
notre famille
et à ses côtés il ya marie dominique il
y à guillaume et il y à nathalie vous le
savez si j'ai voulu françois-xavier
c'est parce que je crois que la
reconstruction de la droite ne se fera
pas en baissant le regard une droite qui
assume ses idées sereinement
tranquillement mais qui ne s'excuse pas
de ses valeurs la droite n'a jamais
gagné en s'excusant de ce qu'elle était
et ma conviction depuis le début
contrairement à ce que parfois certains
pensent c'est que ça n'est pas quand on
assume au grand jour qui en est qu on ne
rassemble pas bien au contraire et je
veux ici témoigner devant vous de ma
reconnaissance pour hervé morin nathalie
tu l'a rappelé et merci à toi à l'image
de ce que vous faites avec françois et
bien ce que moi je vois c'est cette
union de la droite et du centre qui nous
porte dans cette campagne nous sommes
bien sur la liste des républicains mais
nous sommes plus que ça nous sommes
aussi la liste d'union de la droite et
du centre
cette union que nous avons retrouvé avec
les centristes qui eux n'ont jamais
trahi contrairement à françois bayrou
qui a complètement trahi ce qu'était la
vocation initiale du centrisme dans
notre pays et bien grâce à cela nous
plantons les graines qui seront nos
victoires de demain et nos victoires de
demain c'est celle qui nous porterons
pour nos municipal qui nous porterons
pour les départementales et régionales
et qu'ils nous porteront pour la
présidentielle c'est ce rassemblement de
la droite et du centre qui dont nous
portons la première pierre aujourd'hui
dans cette élection européenne
merci à toi nathalie et mercière des 207
m
alors nous parlons de civilisation quand
les pères fondateurs ont pris ce drapeau
quand il choisit sur ce drapeau ils ont
mis les étoiles de la couronne de la
vierge quand le général de gaulle prend
la main d'un démarreur et qu'il choisit
la cathédrale de reims que font-ils ce
qu'ils font je vous le dis ça n'est pas
une construction administrative ce
qu'ils font je vous le dis ce n'est pas
bruxelles ce qu'ils font ça n'est pas la
commission européenne ce n'est pas
l'union européenne aussi respectable sur
la soit il ce qu'ils font c'est quelque
chose de bien plus grand ce qu'ils font
c'est un projet de civilisation
ce qu'ils font c'est qu'en s'appuyant
sur nos racines
ils veulent redonner un avenir à
l'europe détruite par la violence et la
barbarie de la guerre ce qu'ils font
c'est qu'ils portent cette interrogation
dans ce moment si difficile pour
l'europe réduite en cendres comment
peut-on assurer un avenir aux messages
de l'europe
pourquoi sommes nous là nous sommes là
exactement pour la même question
nous sommes portent également exact e
mans par le même attachement aux valeurs
de l'europe et nous sommes portés par la
même inquiétude qui nous taraude est-ce
que face à la chine face aux états unis
face à l'islamisme
face à la question du déclin de notre
économie sommes nous condamnés à voir
notre pays et notre continent changé de
nature
silencieusement ou y at il un autre
destin peut-on retrouver un souffle
peut-on retrouver un an vit une envie
alors quand on nous demande quelle
europe voulez-vous nous notre sujet
n'est pas de savoir si on veut une
europe fédéraliste ou si on veut une
europe souverainiste
nous l'europe que nous voulons c'est
l'europe des projets quand on nous
demande quelle europe nous voulons nous
l'europe que nous voulons c'est l'europe
qui parce qu'elle sait qui elle est et
capable d'imposer sa puissance dans le
monde
nous l'europe que nous voulons c'est une
europe qui n'a pas oublié son identité
l'europe que nous voulons c'est l'europe
civilisation c'est cette europe là que
nous
ton dans ce jour de fête de l'europe
plus que jamais une civilisation une âme
pour qu'il y ait une civilisation
il faut d'abord des frontières des
frontières ce n'est pas un gros mot
quand romulus et rémus fondre hommes il
trace un sillon pour marquer quoi pour
marquer clairement que ce sont eux qui
décideront qui entrera et qui n'entrera
pas à l'intérieur de la cité
les frontières ça définit ce qui est
dehors et ce qui est à l'intérieur
l'europe ne peut pas être une
construction infinie le président de la
république a accepté qu'à partir de juin
comme par hasard au lendemain des
élections européennes
les négociations pour l'entrée de
l'albanie à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne s'ouvre c'est une folie
l'albanie est un pays qui est marqué par
la corruption
l'albanie est un pays dont le niveau de
vie et la situation économique n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec des
standards qui permettent de les intégrer
à l'intérieur de l'union européenne
nous nous exigeons et les français ont
le droit à la vérité de savoir si oui ou
non la france opposera son veto à
l'ouverture des négociations avec
l'albanie
tous les députés qui sont sur notre
liste ont signé une charte d'engagement
ils voteront contre toute décision
pendant leur mandat qui ouvrira la voie
à des élargissements supplémentaires
et de ce point de vue nadine bien sûr
cela suppose d'arrêter et c'est le
projet commun que nous avons avec les
allemands de la cdu ou les négociations
avec la turquie une bonne fois pour
toutes qu'on arrête ce cinéma
la turquie n'est pas dans l'union
européenne on arrête les négociations
avec la turquie pour qu'il y ait des
frontières françois-xavier tu en a parlé
il faut aussi qu'elle soit protégée
et oui la vraie générosité
tu aimes cité pegi
c'est un moteur extraordinaire souvent
très lucide peggy avait l'habitude de
dire rien et généreux comme la fermeté
est rien et inhumain comme la lâcheté
quand on donne ce faux espoirs qui
pousse toute cette jeunesse africaine
sur ces chemins qui aboutit à ces
visages hagards qui arrive ensuite dans
nos villes en étant déracinés dans un
continent qui a dépassé depuis longtemps
son intégration
cela ça n'est pas la vraie générosité
la seule vraie générosité c'est celle
qui consiste à se battre pour que
l'avenir de la jeunesse africaine soit
en afrique et non pas pour que l'avenir
de la jeunesse africaine soit en europe
ça c'est la vraie générosité le devoir
de l'europe c'est de développer les
universités en afrique c'est de
développer l'économie en afrique est de
faire en sorte que la jeunesse africaine
reste en afrique ça c'est la vraie
générosité mais pour qu'il y ait une
civilisation il faut qu'il y ait un
projet il faut qu'il y ait des choses en
commun à construire pas les normes pas
ces normes absurde
nous étions il ya à peine une semaine
fabien tu t'en souviens sur une
exploitation
alsacienne qui fabrique des asperges et
bien les pauvres pour réussir juste à
faire des logements pour loger les gens
qui venaient pour récolter les asperges
ils ont affaire à toute une série de
normes sur la taille des lits superposés
sur la taille des portes sur la taille
des locaux ils finissent en est
tellement décourager qu'on aboutit à l
inverse de ce qu on voulait faire le
résultat qui ne font même plus de locaux
pour pouvoir loger leurs saisonniers et
on a même réussi à faire d'énormes en
centimètres sur la taille des aspects
mais dans quel pays vit-on dans quelle
europe
vidon stop et la france a tort et la
france a tort de se croire plus
intelligente que les autres nous avec la
folie de notre esprit cartésien
ou quand il y à une norme les allemands
ont le bon sens de prendre la norme la
plus simple et nous parce que nous
pensons être les plus intelligents nous
prenons la norme qui décourage tout ceux
qui travaillent et qui entreprennent
stop les normes
arrêtez d'emmerder les français comme le
disait pompidou par contre nous voulons
des projets pourquoi l'europe ne se
concentre pas sur ce projet merveilleux
qui consistera à fédérer tous les
laboratoires de recherche de l'europe et
les faire travailler tous ensemble sur
ce qui est un des fléaux du 21e siècle
les maladies neurodégénératives la
maladie d'alzheimer pour toute personne
qu'il a vécu c'est une épreuve terrible
quand vous ressentez au fur et à mesure
du temps qui passe
la perte du contact avec l'être cher que
les souvenirs s'estompent que la
possibilité de dialoguer partager les
moments heureux s'estompe et qu'elle
arrive et vous avez l'impression que non
seulement la mort et venir mais que pire
que ça on vous a enlevé avant la mort de
celui que vous aimiez la possibilité
d'échanger avec lui tu une épreuve
psychologique c'est une épreuve physique
je n'en connais pas de plus douloureuses
dans une famille cette manne
10 d'alzheimer elle peut être vaincue
j'en suis sûr les chercheurs nous disent
qu'ils ont énormément progressé
je croirais à une europe cette europe
des projets que nous aimions qui soit
capable de dire dans les cinq ans qui
viennent nous allons faire de notre
grande cause européenne la recherche de
la réponse contre les maladies
neurodégénératives et contre alzheimer
et que demain l'europe puisse dire avec
fierté
nous sommes le continent qui a porté au
monde la réponse contre ce fléau
cette europe là c'est celle que j'aime
cette europe c'est celle des projets
c'est celle qui travaille c'est celle
qui cherche et pas celle qui offre à la
marchandisation tout le corps humain
sans comprendre qu'il ya des limites à
l'éthique c'est cette europe à laquelle
j'aspire
et oui bien sûr françois xavier tu l'as
dit l'europe du travail
nous ne faisons plus du social nous
faisons de l'assistanat
nous n'entendons plus la main aux gens
pour les aider à se redresser
ma grand mère avait l'habitude de dire
la meilleure manière d'aider quelqu'un
sait de lui apprendre à pêcher du
poisson c'est pas de lui donner du
poisson chaque jour comment avons nous
pu devenir un continent est un pays dans
lequel il y à des entrepreneurs qui
chaque jour cherche des gens pour
travailler et qui n'en trouvent pas
comment at on pu devenir un pays dans
lequel vous avez des artisans des
agriculteurs des commerçants qui se
donne du mal et qu'ils ont l'impression
d'être les seuls à le faire
vous connaissez mes positions à la
matière la vraie solidarité c'est
d'aider les gens à revenir sur le chemin
du travail
c'est pour cela que je demande qu'on
contrepartie du rsa il puisse y avoir
systématiquement des heures de travail
d'intérêt général
saint gobain pam saint gobain pam et
quelle meilleure illustration gérard toi
qui était battu pour la
réindustrialisation de notre pays
quelle meilleure illustration de nos
folies dans nos marchés publics la
première chose que nous réclamons c'est
la possibilité de pouvoir réserver une
part de nos marchés publics à nos
entreprises c'est quand même la moindre
des choses tous les pays au monde le
font pourquoi l'europe ne pourrait-elle
pas le faire saint gobain entame ils
sont allé installer une usine en chine
et puis un jour les chinois qui après
bien avoir surveillé ce qu'il faisait
après leur avoir pris leurs secrets
leurs brevets après s'être mis à
produire ce que saint gobain pam savait
produire
après avoir installé eux mêmes des
usines en chine capable de faire les
tuyaux ont décidé que maintenant il
était temps de fermer le robinet et ils
ont expliqué à lusinchi était là bas
qu'elle n'avait plus le droit de
produire qu'elles n'étaient plus adaptés
aux normes et que donc il fallait songer
à arrêter de produire en chine et nous
nous avons accepté parce qu'on ne peut
pas commercer comme on veut ans seen on
ne peut pas s'installer comme on vend si
l'on ne peut pas vendre comme on veut en
chine mais en revance les chinois eux
pourraient venir acheter ce qu'ils
veulent en chine vendre comme ils
veulent en chine et la vendre comme ils
veulent en europe et produire comme ils
valent en europe
mais où est la raison dans tout cela est
maintenant saint gobain pam serait
revendue aux chinois qui se sont
arrangés pour faire perdre des millions
d'euros à ce fleuron industriel de la
lorraine en chine
eh bien je ne me résigne pas il faut
retrouver le sens d'un patriotisme
industriel dans lequel on défend d'abord
nos propres entreprises à l'échelle
européenne une civilisation enfin c'est
savoir qui nous sommes
oui
cette civilisation et fragile parce
qu'elle est attaquée
certains pronostiquaient la fin de
l'histoire c'est tout au contraire le
retour de l'histoire et d'histoire la
plus violente
c'est le retour de cet affrontement
entre les civilisations comment ne pas
le comprendre ceux qui tournent leurs
armes contre nous ne sont bien souvent
pas nés en dehors d'europe et de france
ils sont nés chez nous la france et
l'europe vont tout donner tout leur
générosité
et pourtant ils ont tourné leur armes
contre le pays le continent qu'il aura
tout donné
il déteste tout ce que nous sommes et
ils veulent détruire ce qu'est la
civilisation européenne et nous nous
faisons preuve d'une naïveté coupable
nous ne réagissons pas face à
l'islamisme intégriste
alors qu'il est indispensable de prendre
les mesures qui sont aujourd'hui les
seuls capables de faire cette réaction
au début du 20e siècle quand la france
décide de mettre en place les règles de
la laïcité elle demande à l'église
catholique profondément de s'adapter et
elle prend des mesures qui étaient
parfois des mesures très dures et
aujourd'hui nous sommes incapables face
à l'islamisme intégriste de prendre les
mesures qui s'imposent eh bien nous
demandons qu'on sorte de cette naïveté
ne demandons que soit mis en place un
pacte contre l'islamisme intégriste à
l'échelle européenne qui permette de
prendre les mesures indispensables
d'abord fermer toutes les mosquées
salafistes sur le continent européen
c'est indispensable ensuite interdire
aux imams qui prêchent la haine
chaque vendredi à l'ombre des mosquées
et font leur travail de propagande et de
haine quand un imam presse la haine je
ne comprends pas que la république
continue à l'autoriser à officier chaque
vendredi qu'on sorte de france et
d'europe tous les imams qui prêchent la
haine
on ne peut pas continuer à laisser ces
réseaux se diffuser c'est nous
et enfin s'agissant des jihadistes vous
savez je suis allé à mossoul
j'ai vu ce qu'était la barbarie de dèche
et des djihadistes
j'ai vu le visage de ces familles y dit
qu'ils avaient été transformés en
esclaves sexuelles vendu d'un combattant
dèche à l'autre et qui était revenue
brisé par la souffrance j'ai vu au coeur
de mossoul
cet immeuble où on mettait des gens tout
en haut
en leur voile en la tête pour qu'il ne
voit pas ce qui allait leur arriver et
on les précipitaient pour qu'ils agonise
au pied de l'immeuble avec le cou brisé
pendant des heures et des heures
tout ça parce qu'il n'était pas de la
religion musulmane
j'ai vu ce terrain de foot où les
combattants des shows s'amusait à faire
jouer des gamins de 10 ans au football
avec les têtes décapitées de leur ennemi
j'ai vu des familles au coeur de mossoul
qui ont perdu tous leurs enfants parce
qu'ils étaient chrétiens parce qu'ils
étaient orthodoxe je ne peux pas
imaginer une seule seconde que notre
pays et la naïveté de faire revenir ceux
qui ont commis cette barbarie sur le sol
européen le président de la république
et le gouvernement ont d'ores et déjà
accepté que 200 djihadistes reviennent
en france elles sont déjà revenus stop
que nous faut-il nous nous demandons une
chose très claire que l'europe fasse un
tribunal international
qu'ils soient situés en irak que ce
tribunal international permettent de
juger les djihadistes là où ils ont
commis leur crime qu'il soit condamné là
où ils ont commis leur crime et qu'il
reste là où ils ont commis leur crime
les jihadistes n'ont pas à revenir sur
le sol français et sur le sol européen
et oui arnaud marine le pen déteste
tellement l'europe qu'elle vote même
contre ce qui permet de protéger la
france elle a refusé de voter contre ce
logiciel qui permettait de surveiller
les gens qui embarquait à l'inter des
avions et les terroristes en expliquant
ce qui permet de mesurer à quel point
marine le pen n'est de toute évidence
pas à la hauteur en osant expliqué que
les terroristes ne prennent pas l'avion
mais comment un responsable politique
peut encore dire cela après ce qui s'est
passé le 11 septembre
madame le pen mohamed merah les frères
kwasi avait pris l'avion pour se rendre
en afghanistan et pour se rendre au
yémen
vous êtes irresponsable de tenir de tels
propos dans une époque comme la nôtre
[Applaudissements]
mais je voudrais finir par cela le mal
est plus profond et l'espoir peut-être
la cl on le regarde et qu'on y apporte
les remèdes
vous êtes ici dans une terre de lorraine
admirable qui a été construite par des
flux de populations qui sont venus ici
en venant parfois d'autres pays
européens
en venant de pologne en venant belgique
en venant d'italie en venant d'espagne
en venant du portugal
revenant évidemment du sud de la
méditerranée et en venant ici en ayant
ce discours qui a toujours forcé mon
admiration pour leur enfant consistant à
leur dire on vient ici pour travailler
ne me fait pas honte
tiens toi bien respecte ce que te dit le
maître apprend le français apprend à
lire apprend à écrire donne-toi du mal à
compter de ce jour
ton pays c'est la france
la civilisation c'est la civilisation
européenne cela c'était l'intégration
qui a permis petit à petit de façonner
ce qu'était le visage de la république
française et que s'est-il passé
mais nous avons inversé le devoir
d'intégration nous avons oublié que la
vraie générosité c'est de transmettre ce
que nous sommes nous avons perdu notre
fierté et nous avons cru qu'à cueillir
l'autre sait s'adapter à l'autre alors
que c'est au contraire lui transmettre
ce qu on est pour qu'il puisse faire
sien le pays dans lequel il s'est
installé
quelle erreur nous avons tous été
marqués par l'incendié de notre dame
nous avons tous été marqués par cet
incendie parce que c'était la france qui
brûlait nous avons tous été marqués par
cet incendie parce que soudain était
évident alors que je me suis souvent
battu pour imposer cette idée et death
to d'un évident que bien évidemment que
les racines de la france est chrétienne
mais il ya des incendies qui sont moins
visibles
il ya des incendies qui sont plus sous
terrain il y a les incendies qui
attirent moins l'attention et qui ronge
de l'intérieur de la même manière notre
civilisation
à chaque fois qu'on accepte que dans une
salle de classe on renonce à un voyage
de classe à reims parce que certains
disent ça n'est pas compatible avec ma
religion 7
un incendie à chaque fois que dans un
quartier une femme n'a plus le choix
2 la façon de s'habiller qu'elle est
obligée de porter le voile parce que
certains intégristes lui impose cette un
incendie à chaque fois que dans un
hôpital un médecin homme se voit la
conte se voit contesté la possibilité
d'intervenir sur une patiente femme
parce qu'on lui explique que dans les
règles de la religion on ne peut pas
faire comme ça 7
un incendie à chaque fois que l'on
recule un peu sur ce que nous sommes
7 un incendie pourquoi je n'ai jamais
voulu lâcher sur ce dossier en apparence
si anodin des crèches
parce que j'ai toujours été convaincu
que les crèches est un petit bout de ce
que nous sommes et qu'à chaque fois que
nous faisons un pas en arrière
à chaque fois que nous choisissons le
chemin de la soumission
nous ne construisons pas l'avenir de
notre pays
nous sommes la france nous sommes
l'europe
ici nous sommes en lorraine vous êtes
dans cette terre qui était le joyau du
croisement des grandes routes
commerciales de l' empire romain vous
êtes dans cette terre qui a été édifié
patiemment par des abbayes qui ont
contribué à la défricher et à lui donner
son premier essor économique
vous êtes ici à pont-à-mousson dans une
des premières universités au rayonnement
international qui avait été créé à
l'époque moderne et qui à l'époque forcé
le respect en attirant les talents du
monde
vous êtes dans une terre qui a toujours
été capable d'innover d'entreprendre
d'aller chercher les brevets demain de
construire ce qui forçait le respect par
la qualité de ses manufactures puis
ensuite par la qualité de ses industries
une terre qui a contribué à édifier la
réussite de la révolution industrielle
du 19e siècle et qui avait projeté la
lorraine au coeur de l'europe
vous êtes dans une terre qui a souffert
mais vous êtes dans une terre qui n'a
jamais renoncé
vous êtes ici dans cette ville de
pont-à-mousson qui a été quasiment rasé
au moment de 14-18 par les tirs de
l'artillerie allemande et où les
bibliothèques des moines de prémontré où
tous les vestiges du passé avaient été
réduits à néant
vous êtes dans une terre qui a à nouveau
connu l'outragé du temps avec la seconde
guerre mondiale où elle a à nouveau été
détruites et où la libération de
pont-à-mousson a été fait notamment par
les résistants qui ont contribué à
reconstruire l'avenir de la france dans
cette terre de lorraine qui a donné la
croix de lorraine à l'emblème du
mouvement gaulliste qui a contribué à la
libération de la france et de l'europe
vous êtes dans cette terre où même quand
la chapelle jeanne d'arc avait été
détruite jamais vous n'avez baisser les
bras vous êtes dans cette terre qu'est
plus qu'aucune autre est resté fidèle au
message du général de gaulle que je
chéris le plus pour faire face à
l'adversité
il fallait que nous restions nous mêmes
fidèle à une conception de l'homme
disait le général de gaulle qui nous a
faits tels que nous sommes faire valoir
dans le tumulte du monde ce que nous
sommes
pour servir et pour survivre de quoi
aurions nous montrent comment ne pas
comprendre que cette histoire est la
meilleure garantie de notre avenir
comment ne pas comprendre que si l'on
veut refonder l'europe rétablir la
france il faut faire les deux à la fois
retrouver la fierté de ce que nous avons
été pour retrouver l'audace de ce que
nous serons comprendre tout simplement
qu'il faut adresser un message qu'ils
soient simples qui était le message de
saint-augustin le devoir d'intégration
ne doit pas être inversée c'est à celui
qui vient chez nous de s'adapter à ce
qu'est notre mode de vie et ça n'est pas
à notre mode de vie de s'adapter à celui
qui vient chez nous c'est celle
générosité que je veux que nous
retrouvions
refonder le rap rétablir la france c'est
au nom de ce débat que je vous demande
de vous engager dans cette campagne des
européennes
refonder l'europe rétablir la france
comprendre que cette histoire nous
pouvons tout à la fois en être fier et
que nous devons en être digne comme je
suis consternée quand je vois que dans
cette campagne le seul but du
rassemblement national et de battre
emmanuel macron et que le seul but d'en
mars est de battre le rassemblement
national
eh bien nous nous vous proposons une
toute autre bataille nous nous vous
proposons la seule bataille qui vaille
en politique je n'en connais pas de plus
belle c'est celle qui consiste à
réaffirmer son identité c'est celle qui
consiste à redonner un souffle à sa
civilisation
nous avons besoin de vous il reste une
poignée de jours pour permettre
d'inverser le cours des choses
il reste une poignée de jours pour
transformer cet espoir qui a commencé à
se lever dans cette campagne en une
marée qui ne s'arrêtera plus il reste
une poignée de jours pour redresser les
choses
il reste une poignée de jours pour
porter le débat qui a toujours été le
nôtre sauver tout à la fois ce qu'est
l'identité de notre pays et refonder
l'europe dont nous avons besoin
battez-vous au nom de sang et les nous
nous avons besoin de vous il reste une
poignée de jours pour réaffirmer la voix
de la droite et du centre dans notre
pays
vive la france et vive l'europe
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]